I know so many people who have films that they have watched over and over, and I have never really gotten that. I always feel like there are so many films that I haven't seen-- why would I watch one again? But we get into these conversations, and there always comes a moment where I'm asked, well, what is the film that you've seen the most? And then I have to admit, it's The Poseidon Adventure.
我认识很多人，他们都有反复观看的电影，但我从来没法理解这一点。我总觉得还有那么多没看过的电影，为什么要把一部电影看两遍呢？但当我们谈论起这个话题时，总会有人问我：你把哪部电影看的最多次？然后我不得不承认，是《海神号遇险记》。
Which I know is not a good film. It's this '70s movie about an ocean liner that gets hit by a tsunami, flips upside down, and the passengers try to make their way to safety. It's part of an entire genre of films, disaster films, that have never gotten any respect. Nobody thinks of these films as art, but I loved it at the time when I saw it.
我知道那不是一部好电影。这是一部 70 年代的电影，讲的是一艘远洋客轮遭遇海啸翻了个底朝天，乘客们设法逃生。它属于一种一直以来都不被尊重的电影类型——灾难片。没人会把这些电影当成艺术，但我看的时候确实很喜欢。
It felt big, and it felt important, and serious. And I remember it was very emotional. And the reason that I saw it so many times, that this is the film that I saw more than any other, was not because I loved the film. It was because of where I saw it.
它看起来宏大、重要且严肃。我记得当时感触很深。我之所以看过那么多遍，之所以这是我看过次数最多的电影，并不是因为我有多爱这部电影，而是因为我是在哪里看的。
I was on vacation. We didn't take many vacations when I was a kid, but on one of them, we stayed at this hotel in Florida where the rooms had this thing where they offered a couple movies all day long. And this was so long ago, in the 1970s. My sisters and I, we had never seen anything like that. Even cable TV was rare back then.
当时我在度假。小时候我们很少去度假，但有一次，我们住在佛罗里达的一家酒店里，那里的房间全天循环播放几部电影。那是很久以前的事了，在 20 世纪 70 年代。我和姐姐们从没见过那种东西。那时候连有线电视都很罕见。
The Poseidon Adventure was the film that they offered, and my sister Karen and I, we ate it up.
《海神号遇险记》就是他们提供的电影，我和姐姐凯伦看得津津有味。
That was the movie we watched over and over again, yeah.
没错，那就是我们反复观看的电影。
Oh, so this was like a very important movie.
哦，所以这真是一部很重要的电影。
That's Karen and her son Zach, my nephew, who we tried to explain this to recently.
那是凯伦和她的儿子扎克，我的侄子，我们最近试图向他解释这件事。
So we ended up watching it on TV, like at night, if our parents went out to dinner, or if it was a rainy day. Yeah, we loved it.
我们最后是在电视上看的，比如晚上父母出去吃饭的时候，或者下雨天的时候。是的，我们很喜欢它。
The way that I remember it is that the hotel just had this movie on a loop. And just as soon as it would finish, it would start again. And the way I remember it is, that every time we would come into the hotel room you could turn on the TV, and you'd be somewhere in The Poseidon Adventure.
我的记忆是，酒店当时在循环播放这部电影。刚一放完就会重新开始。我的记忆是，每次我们走进酒店房间打开电视，总会看到《海神号遇险记》的某个片段。
That sounds vaguely familiar to me. I don't totally remember that, but that might be right. Yeah.
那听起来确实有点印象。我不完全记得了，但可能是对的。是的。
And I remember it having a lot of feeling. Do remember it having a lot of feeling?
而且我记得它很有感染力。你记得它很有感染力吗？
What does that mean, having a lot of feeling?
什么叫很有感染力？
I remember feeling a lot of emotions.
我记得当时感受到了很多情绪。
Yeah, well, it's scary, and you're really invested in their journey to escape alive. I don't think I'm giving anything away by saying that.
是的，它很吓人，你会真正投入到他们逃生的旅程中。说这话我应该不算剧透吧。
Sort of are.
算是一点点吧。
Here at the radio show these last few weeks, we've been talking about the random films that people have strong attachments to, thinking that might be a good episode of the show. And I started to think about The Poseidon Adventure, and I wondered what it would be like to see it again. Like, would it have any feeling? Would any of it feel the way it did to me as a kid? Would it feel that way to Karen?
过去几周，我们在电台节目里一直在谈论人们强烈依恋的那些电影，觉得这可能会是一个很好的节目主题。我开始想到《海神号遇险记》，我想知道再看一遍会是什么感觉。它还会有感染力吗？它还会像我小时候那样让我感同身受吗？凯伦还会那种感觉吗？
So my sister and I, we watched it. And I invited Zach, too, since he's the age that we were when we watched it back in the '70s. He's 13. I was 14 at the time. Karen was 11. And I want to say, I did not expect Zach to like it. He does not like a lot of films. And right away, the very first scene let us know the kind of film we were in for.
于是我和姐姐一起看了这部电影。我也邀请了扎克，因为他现在的年龄和我们当年看电影时一样大。他 13 岁。我当时 14 岁，凯伦 11 岁。我得说，我没指望扎克会喜欢它。他不喜欢很多电影。但第一个镜头就让我们知道这部电影是什么风格了。
A little boy visits the bridge of the SS Poseidon, this ocean liner in the middle of a big storm. And the little boy is greeted by the captain, who's played by Leslie Nielsen-- who, at this point, had not made the career transition to parodying characters like this captain.
一个小男孩参观“海神号”的驾驶台，这艘远洋客轮正处在暴风雨中心。小男孩受到了船长的欢迎，船长由莱斯利·尼尔森饰演——他在当时还没转型去演那些恶搞角色。
Mr. Shelby, you've picked a particularly fascinating moment to accept my invitation. These waves don't bother you, huh?
谢尔比先生，你选择了一个非常迷人的时刻来接受我的邀请。这些海浪没打扰到你吧？
I've surfed up to 18 feet, but these look more like 30.
我冲过 18 英尺的浪，但这些看起来更像 35 英尺。
35 to be exact.
准确地说是 35 英尺。
Wow, surf's really up.
哇，浪真的很高。
Oh, my.
天哪。
What's "oh, my"?
什么叫“天哪”？
Those lines. So cheesy.
那些台词。太俗气了。
I didn't remember how wincey the acting got in some places. When Ernest Borgnine shows up, it's clear that the 1956 Oscar winner for Best Actor is not in one of his best roles.
我不记得有些地方的表演竟然那么让人尴尬。当欧内斯特·博格宁出现时，很明显这位 1956 年的奥斯卡最佳男主角并没有发挥出他最好的水平。
Linda, you hear me?
琳达，你听到我说话了吗？
Why is he so angry?
他为什么那么生气？
Borgnine does seem to shout nearly every one of his lines in the film. One thing that kind of stunned me and I did not expect seeing the film again was how much of the dialogue I remember from decades ago. And I was also surprised to realize-- and I do not know what this says about me-- the lines that that I remember the most are the little comic zingers. You know, like when a crew member is asked if he's married, I know his corny response before he says it.
博格宁在片中几乎是喊出了每一句台词。重看这部电影时有一点让我很震惊，我完全没想到，我竟然还记得几十年前的那么多对话。我同样惊讶地发现——我不知道这说明了我什么——我记得最清楚的台词竟然是那些蹩脚的幽默梗。你知道，比如当船员被问到是否结婚时，我比他说出来之前就知道他那俗气的回答。
Are you married?
你结婚了吗？
No marriage for me, Mrs. Rosen. I've got a mistress.
没结婚，罗森太太。我有位情妇。
What?
什么？
The sea.
大海。
Hey, that's good.
嘿，那很不错。
Something I did remember, and remember liking from the film, was that this was an old-fashioned enough movie that the producers tried to insert some big ideas into the adventure, so it would all mean something. These big ideas are provided by Gene Hackman, who plays a rebellious young priest in a turtleneck, whose big theological idea is a very conveniently helpful one for people who are about to be capsized in the middle of the ocean.
我记得并喜欢这部电影的一点是，这还是一部够老派的电影，制片人试图在冒险中加入一些宏大的思想，让这一切变得有意义。这些宏大的思想由吉恩·哈克曼提供，他饰演一位穿着高领毛衣的叛逆年轻牧师，他的神学思想对于那些在大洋深处即将翻船的人来说非常及时且方便。
God doesn't want you to wait for miracles. You have to take matters into your own hands.
上帝不想让你等待奇迹。你必须把命运掌握在自己手中。
Don't pray to God to solve your problems.
不要祈求上帝去解决你的问题。
This is from a sermon he delivers early in the film.
这是他电影开头布道时说的。
Have the guts to fight for yourself. God wants brave souls. He wants winners, not quitters. If you can't win, at least try to win!
有胆量为自己而战。上帝想要勇敢的灵魂。他想要赢家，而不是逃兵。如果你不能赢，至少要尝试去赢！
He comes back to this over and over through the film, rallying the passengers to fight on. I loved that as a teenager, that there was this idealistic guy with this principle that he's trying to live by and this idea about God that the film is testing. And I have to say, seeing it today, I still loved it, that they put that in there.
他在电影中反复提到这一点，号召乘客们战斗到底。我年轻时很喜欢这一点，有一个理想主义者，秉持着他试图遵循的原则，以及电影正在检验的关于上帝的观念。我不得不说，今天看的时候，我依然很喜欢他们在电影里加入这些内容。
Anyway, soon enough, right at the stroke of midnight on New Year's Eve, the tsunami hits, the boat flips, the plotline tips. In the wreckage of the upside down New Year's party, Gene Hackman convinces only eight passengers that they shouldn't stay and wait for God to send rescuers, but climb with him to safety.
总之，没过多久，就在新年除夕的午夜，海啸袭来，船翻了，剧情也随之转折。在翻倒的新年派对残骸中，吉恩·哈克曼只说服了八名乘客，让他们不要留在原地等待上帝派人救援，而是和他一起爬向安全地带。
Now please, for God's sake, come with me.
现在请看在上帝的份上，跟我走吧。
They creep from deck to deck, barely escaping the rising waters as they go. The ceilings of the rooms are the floors that they walk on and the floors are the ceilings. There's a fiery upside-down kitchen. They go up slippery ladders and inverted staircases. And by the time they start dying, one by one, for Karen and me, and even Zach, it's no joke. We're in it. We care.
他们从一层甲板爬到另一层，惊险地逃离上涨的海水。房间的天花板成了他们行走的地面，地面成了天花板。有一个起火的倒挂厨房。他们爬上滑溜溜的梯子和颠倒的楼梯。当他们一个接一个地死去时，对于凯伦、我和扎克来说，这不是开玩笑的。我们全身心投入了进去。我们很在乎。
[GROANING AND SPLASHING]
[呻吟声和水花声]
Did she just have a heart attack? Wait, did she just have a heart attack?
她刚是心脏病发作了吗？等等，她刚心脏病发作了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Wow. That's a pretty random heart attack.
哇，这心脏病发作得太随意了吧。
Not really. Think about the fact that she just did all that swimming and she's out of shape.
不完全是。想想看，她刚做完那一系列游泳动作，而且她身体状况并不好。
After Mrs. Rosen, the menschy grandma in the film dies, her husband discovers her dead body.
罗森太太，也就是电影里那位好心的奶奶去世后，她的丈夫发现了她的尸体。
Oh, that guy's gonna be so sad.
噢，那个人会很难过。
I remember this moment so well.
这一幕我记得太清楚了。
I remember this, too, really well. This was very affecting.
我也记得很清楚。真的很令人动容。
I've been really invested in this movie. It's sort of good.
我完全沉浸在这部电影里了。这片子其实挺好的。
You do feel very invested?
你真的感觉很投入吗？
Yeah. It's like I'm not sure what's gonna happen next, unlike most other movies.
是的。不像大多数其他电影，我不太确定接下来会发生什么。
I'd wondered if Zack was gonna feel the same big feelings that I felt for the film at his age. And he totally did.
我一直在想扎克是否会像我当年那样对这部电影有强烈的感觉。而他完全感受到了。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Wow, she dies? No. Oh, he dies, too? No. They were so close. No.
哇，她死了？不。噢，他也死了？不。他们离成功就差一点点。不。
By the time we get to gene hackman's big climactic speech to God...
当我们看到吉恩·哈克曼对上帝的最后大段独白时……
What more do you want of us? We came all this way no thanks to you.
你还想从我们身上得到什么？我们走到这一步多亏了自己，而不是你。
...it was clear: The Poseidon Adventure, it does its job. It gets to you. But thinking about the experience that Zach had watching the film and the one that I was having, it's so different, right? For me, it was like walking into a room from my childhood home and finding it intact and exactly how I remembered it. Or we would get to a scene and I would remember things I didn't realize I remembered. Is there even a name for that?
很明显：《海神号遇险记》完成了它的使命。它触动了你。但回想扎克观看电影的经历和我自己的经历，它们是如此不同，对吧？对我来说，这就像走进童年家中的一个房间，发现它完好无损，和我记忆中一模一样。或者我们看到某个场景，我会想起自己都没意识到我还记得的事情。这甚至有一个专门的名称吗？
When we watch a movie together, we think we're watching the same thing, but we are not. For me, The Poseidon Adventure is a portal back to that vacation, and being in that hotel room with Karen, and knowing those movie stars from other things they made, and just that whole time in my life. I can't show Zack that movie.
当我们一起看电影时，我们以为我们在看同一个东西，但事实并非如此。对我而言，《海神号遇险记》是一扇通往那个假期的传送门，那里有我和凯伦在酒店房间里的时光，有那些我在其他作品里认识的电影明星，还有我生命中的那段时期。我无法向扎克展示那部电影。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, after months of pandemic when so many of us have been staying home and seeing way more movies than usual, we thought here at our show, let's do a movie night, a show about movies.
好的，来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，经过数月的疫情，我们很多人都待在家里，看的电影比平时多了很多，于是我们想在节目里举办一个电影之夜，一期关于电影的节目。
And in particular, we decided to get people who've watched a film over and over, who see something in it most people don't see, films for which they are an audience of one. Including somebody who went this deep with a video online, and somebody who watched a classic kid's film over and over, a film that so many of us have seen. She loved it, and only learned years later as an adult that what she'd seen was only the first half of the film. Stay with us.
特别地，我们决定找那些把一部电影看了又看的人，他们看到了大多数人看不到的东西，那是他们专属的电影。包括一个人，他通过网上视频深入钻研一部电影；还有一个人，她反复观看一部经典的儿童片，那部电影我们许多人都看过。她很喜欢它，直到多年后长大成人，才知道她当年只看了电影的前半部分。请继续收听。
Act One, Putting the Ease in Disease.
第一幕：轻松面对疾病。
So back when the pandemic first took hold, a lot of people were watching or re-watching the movie Contagion, which originally came out in 2011. Maybe you've seen it. It's about a deadly and fast-spreading virus that is spread by respiratory droplets, goes around the world. Governments fail to contain it.
疫情刚爆发时，很多人都在看或重看 2011 年上映的电影《传染病》。也许你看到过。讲的是一种致命且传播迅速的病毒，通过呼吸道飞沫传播，遍布全球。政府未能将其遏制。
And I think we watch films like that or read books about the 1918 flu because it just scratches this itch, where we just want some way to think about what we're going through right now. And it's nice to just see somebody else go through some version of it.
我认为我们看这类电影或读关于 1918 年流感的书，是因为这正好挠到了痒处，我们只是想找一种方式来思考我们正在经历的事情。看到别人经历某种版本的类似遭遇，感觉也不错。
One of our producers, Sean Cole, has never seen Contagion, but he found himself turning to this other movie, a movie about a virus, that you probably have not heard of. It is a very different spin on the subject. Here's Sean.
我们的制片人之一肖恩·科尔从未看过《传染病》，但他发现自己转而去看了另一部关于病毒的电影，你可能没听说过。它对这个主题有完全不同的演绎。肖恩来为你讲述。
You won't find this movie on Netflix or YouTube or anywhere like that, or at least I couldn't find it that way. I finally had to order a DVD from an online vintage movie store. It's clear my copy was pirated off cable-- skips a lot. And like all of the Contagion geeks, I was floored by some of the parallels to now, especially given that this movie came out in 1968, more than half a century ago.
你在 Netflix、YouTube 或任何类似平台上都找不到这部电影，至少我没找到。我最后不得不从一家在线老电影商店订了一张 DVD。很明显我的拷贝是从有线电视上录制的——跳帧很严重。像所有《传染病》发烧友一样，我被它与当下的诸多相似之处惊呆了，特别是考虑到这部电影是在 1968 年上映的，已经过去半个多世纪了。
For instance, in this movie, instead of a bat, the vector of the virus is a bird, a toucan that stowed away aboard a Greek freighter somewhere near Central America. Then the boat docks in New York Harbor for inspection, and the first mate alerts the military that a lot of the crew is sick.
例如，在这部电影里，病毒载体不是蝙蝠，而是一只鸟——一只在中美洲附近偷渡上一艘希腊货船的巨嘴鸟。然后船只停靠在纽约港进行检查，大副提醒军方，船员中很多人都病了。
We'll have to hold the ship in quarantine indefinitely. If it a virus, my guess, it's a brand new one, some kind of a mutation. No telling how long it'll take to identify it.
我们将不得不无限期地将这艘船隔离。如果这是一种病毒，我猜它是全新的，某种突变体。谁也说不准需要多久才能识别它。
The toucan is still on board, held in a makeshift chicken wire fence. But then it gets loose, flies straight into the city, and starts infecting people. Just a few at first. The mayor of New York, an empty suit motivated mostly by money and poll numbers, holds a press conference, speaking into a microphone labeled WNYC, the public radio station in New York, where I used to work. It was weird.
巨嘴鸟还在船上，被关在临时的铁丝网围栏里。但后来它挣脱了，径直飞进了城市，并开始感染人类。最初只有几个病例。纽约市长，一个主要受金钱和民调数字驱动的草包，举行了一场新闻发布会，对着一个印有 WNYC 标志的麦克风讲话——这是纽约的公共广播电台，我曾经在那里工作过。这太诡异了。
There is absolutely no cause for alarm. Only 47 cases have been reported so far. However, the commissioner of health recommends that you wear a surgical mask when you are out in public.
完全没有理由恐慌。到目前为止仅报告了 47 例病例。然而，卫生局长建议你在公共场合戴上外科口罩。
He holds up a mask exactly like the one I wear every day. After the reporters leave, though, there's deep concern and dread. The health commissioner, an older Anthony Fauci-type, scolds the mayor for underplaying the threat everyone's facing.
他举起了一个口罩，和我每天戴的一模一样。不过记者们离开后，人们感到了深深的忧虑和恐惧。卫生局长，一位老派的安东尼·福奇式人物，责骂市长低估了大家面临的威胁。
True, we got a line on the 47 who reported to doctors, but--
没错，我们掌握了去医生那里报告的 47 例的情况，但是……
But when you feel good, you don't go to a doctor.
但是当你感觉良好时，你是不会去看医生的。
Lord knows how many more have it.
天知道还有多少人感染了。
But the virus only has a life of 10 days or so. You said so yourself.
但病毒只有 10 天左右的生命周期。你自己也说过。
Yes, but somebody who gets it on the 10th day, and has it for another 10 days, and a week after he gets it, he gives it to somebody else and so on. Theoretically, it could go on for years.
是的，但如果有人在第 10 天被感染，又携带了 10 天，而在感染一周后又传染给了别人，以此类推。理论上，这可以持续数年。
Soon, everyone is scurrying around the city in a masked panic. Businesses suffer. A presidential envoy fast tracks the development of a vaccine. If it weren't for the 20-foot-long cop cars and A-line mod dresses, it feels like some of these scenes could've been shot in Manhattan last weekend.
很快，每个人都在戴着口罩的恐慌中在城市里穿梭。企业遭受重创。总统特使加速了疫苗的开发。如果不是因为那 20 英尺长的警车和 A 字型摩登裙装，你会觉得其中一些场景简直就像上周末在曼哈顿拍摄的。
Except, there's one major difference between this film and the Steven Soderberghian Contagion-like reality we're all living in. Because in this movie, the virus is not fatal. It doesn't even cause a fever or a cough. Instead, the main and only symptom is absolute euphoria. That's it. Everyone it infects experiences unbridled happiness and elation. Its victims begin acting kindly to one another, deferential.
不过，这部电影和我们所有人目前所处的史蒂文·索德伯格式《传染病》现实之间有一个主要区别。因为在这部电影里，病毒不是致命的。它甚至不会导致发烧或咳嗽。相反，最主要也是唯一的症状是绝对的欣快感。就是这样。所有感染者都会体验到无拘无束的快乐和兴奋。受害者开始变得彼此友好、恭敬。
In just a couple of days, the city is transformed from this--
仅仅几天，城市就从这样——
Come on, you jerk! The light ain't gonna get any greener!
快点，你个笨蛋！灯不会一直绿的！
Why, you lazy, no good, rotten, stinking--
你个懒惰、没用、烂透了、臭烘烘的……
You're telling me when I came in?
你是说我进来的时候吗？
You're damn right I am!
你他妈说得对！
Who you shoving, mac? You own the sidewalk?
你推谁呢，伙计？这人行道是你家的？
To this.
变成了这样。
Good morning. Nice day, isn't it?
早上好。天气不错，是吧？
I'm sorry.
对不起。
Pardon me.
不好意思。
May I help you?
需要帮忙吗？
The movie's called What's So Bad About Feeling Good? It's a comedy-- a rom com, really. And it is not a good movie, which is why you likely haven't heard of it, even though the lead actors are George Peppard, from Breakfast at Tiffany's and the A-Team, and Mary Tyler Moore from Mary Tyler Moore.
这部电影叫《感觉良好有什么不好？》。这是一部喜剧——确切地说是浪漫喜剧。这不是一部好电影，这就是为什么你很可能没听说过它，尽管主演是《蒂凡尼的早餐》和《天龙特攻队》里的乔治·佩帕德，以及《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》里的玛丽·泰勒·摩尔。
And they do a good job. Pretty much everyone in the cast is really skilled, but the whole production is outlandishly campy and caricaturistic. There are a few very awkward choices. Cartoon word balloons emerge from the toucan's mouth sometimes when it squawks, so you know what it's thinking. Oh, and there's a schmaltzy AM radio theme song, kind of a knockoff of Burt Bacharach.
他们演得不错。演员阵容里的每个人其实都很专业，但整个制作显得极其夸张和脸谱化。有一些非常尴尬的选择。巨嘴鸟尖叫时，嘴里偶尔会冒出卡通气泡，好让你知道它在想什么。哦，还有一首俗气的调频广播主题歌，有点像伯特·巴卡拉克的山寨版。
(SINGING) What's so wrong with that happy sensation, that sense of utter elation? What's so bad about feeling good?
(演唱) 那种快乐的感觉，那种彻底的欢欣，有什么不好呢？感觉良好有什么不好？
That said, it's also a great movie, in the way that silly B movies can be so satisfying, especially the arcane ones that make you feel like a kid watching adults mess up for the first time. I have a greatest hits list of them in my head. Wild in the Streets, about ageist hippies waging a coup against the US government. Invasion of the Bee Girls, about a race of murderous women, who are also bees. Both of which you can watch online for free.
话虽如此，它也是一部很棒的电影，就像愚蠢的 B 级片一样令人满足，尤其是那些神秘的片子，让你感觉像个第一次看着成年人搞砸事情的孩子。我脑子里有一份它们的金曲清单。《Wild in the Streets》，讲述崇尚年龄歧视的嬉皮士对美国政府发动政变。《Invasion of the Bee Girls》，讲述一群凶残的女人，她们也是蜜蜂。这两部电影你都可以在网上免费观看。
But since it's so hard to find a copy of this movie, let me just continue taking you through the plot in a kind of abbreviated, radioified Cliff's Notes version, for your movie not-going enjoyment.
但因为很难找到这部电影的副本，让我继续以一种简略的、广播版的“书摘”形式为你介绍剧情，让你享受看电影而无需真的去看。
So George Peppard and Mary Tyler Moore are Pete and Liz, two characters who are tailor-made for this particular plot, because they don't contain an ounce of euphoria. They're brooding, existentialist arty-types that have dropped out of society, living in the East Village. They'd be boyfriend and girlfriend, if they believed in that sort of thing.
乔治·佩帕德和玛丽·泰勒·摩尔饰演的皮特和利兹，是两个为这个特定情节量身打造的角色，因为他们身上没有一丝欣快感。他们是忧郁的、存在主义的艺术类型，退出了社会，住在东村。如果他们相信那种事的话，他们就是男女朋友了。
For no discernible reason-- or maybe cause the script wasn't working and they had to fix it quickly-- there's a lot of voiceover by these two.
毫无缘由地——或者是因为剧本行不通，他们必须快速修补——这两个人有大量的旁白。
A couple years ago, I was just like the rest of you conformists. I was in advertising, name on the door, carpet on the floor, an ulcer, headaches, the whole bit. But I wised up to that phony world and came down here. So did Liz. She was on the treadmill, too.
几年前，我和你们这些循规蹈矩的人一样。我在广告业工作，门上挂着我的名字，地板铺着地毯，有溃疡、头痛，那一套全都有。但我看穿了那个虚假的世界，来到了这里。利兹也一样。她也在跑步机上拼命。
I sure was. Uptown supper clubs, singing schmaltzy songs to the drunks, fighting to get to the top of the ladder. And then my heart got into the act, and somebody stepped on it. Pills to sleep, pills to stay awake. Finally, I asked myself, for what? This was the answer.
我当然是。市中心的晚餐俱乐部，对醉汉唱着俗气的歌，拼命往梯子顶端爬。然后我的心也参与了进来，有人踩在了它上面。吃药睡觉，吃药保持清醒。最后，我问自己，为了什么？这就是答案。
"This" being the communal building they live in with a tribe of other unhappy nihilists collecting unemployment. They all look a little like cave people at a gallery opening. One of them spends every hour of every day completely enveloped inside of a sack. They call her the Sack.
“这就是”指的是他们居住的公共建筑，里面住着一堆其他失落的虚无主义者，领取救济金。他们看起来都有点像在画廊开幕式上的穴居人。其中一个人每天每时每刻都完全包裹在麻袋里。他们叫她“麻袋”。
Since the problems of life are insoluble, one should draw into complete isolation and live a life of total non-involvement with other people.
既然生活的问题无法解决，一个人就应该完全孤立，过一种与其他人完全不参与的生活。
The Sack is right.
“麻袋”说得对。
Meanwhile, a little ways downtown, the Faucian commissioner of health pretty quickly figures out how the virus works.
与此同时，在市中心不远处，福奇式的卫生局长很快搞清楚了病毒的工作原理。
And it has to be transmitted by respiration. All that bird has to do is get within breathing distance of somebody and pop goes the weasel.
而且它必须通过呼吸传播。那只鸟只要进入某人的呼吸范围内，砰，黄鼠狼就跳出来了。
Cue the toucan, who flies into Pete and Liz's window one morning while they're sleeping, loiters for a minute next to Pete's face and leaves. Pete wakes up early.
轮到巨嘴鸟了，它一天早上在皮特和利兹睡觉时飞进了他们的窗户，在皮特脸边徘徊了一会儿，然后离开了。皮特很早就醒了。
What are you doing up?
你怎么起得这么早？
And heads up to the roof. Liz climbs up after him concerned.
然后他上了屋顶。利兹担心地跟了上去。
Pete.
皮特。
Come here.
过来。
What happened?
怎么了？
Come here. Look, in this cruddy pile of junk, a flower.
过来。看，在这堆肮脏的垃圾堆里，有一朵花。
Pete, what's wrong? What's the matter with you.
皮特，你怎么了？你到底怎么了？
I don't know. Ever since I got up, I've been feeling strange, kind of. I don't think I can explain it to you, but everything seems different. Hey, listen.
我不知道。自从我起床，我就感觉很奇怪。我觉得我没法向你解释，但一切似乎都不同了。嘿，听。
To what, the traffic?
听什么，交通声？
Kids laughing.
孩子们的笑声。
You know why they're laughing? 'Cause they're not old enough to read the newspaper. You take a look at the front page, and then try laughing. The world's a stinking, hopeless mess. Oh, Pete, you're sick. You know, sometimes a high fever can make you feel this way.
你知道他们为什么笑吗？因为他们还没到能读报纸的年纪。你看看头版，然后再试着笑出来。这个世界是个臭气熏天的、毫无希望的烂摊子。噢，皮特，你病了。你知道，有时候高烧会让人有这种感觉。
I feel great.
我感觉棒极了。
That's what I mean.
我就是这个意思。
At this point, it's worth noting why someone might want to make a film about the need for euphoria in 1968. The front page Liz is talking about would include headlines like "Martin Luther King Is Slain in Memphis," "Robert Kennedy Dead," "Police Battle Demonstrators in the Streets," also "Viet Cong Storm US Embassy."
这时候，值得注意的是为什么有人想在 1968 年拍一部关于需要欣快感的电影。利兹所说的头版新闻可能包括“马丁·路德·金在孟菲斯被杀”、“罗伯特·肯尼迪去世”、“警察在街头与示威者搏斗”，还有“越共袭击美国大使馆”。
We were a nation at war, both abroad and with itself, with protests and riots in cities across the country, and a presidential candidate running on a platform of law and order, and also courting segregationists. And given all that, you might ask, what is so bad about feeling good? Which is what the mayor in the movie wanted to know.
我们是一个处于战争中的国家，在国外以及国内，全国各地的城市都在进行抗议和骚乱，还有一位总统候选人在竞选平台主打法律与秩序，同时讨好种族隔离主义者。考虑到这一切，你可能会问，感觉良好有什么不好？这也是电影里的市长想知道的问题。
In one of the first crisis management meetings with his cabinet, they're running down the symptoms for him, and tell him the virus stops people from brooding. But it's worse than that.
在与内阁成员举行的第一次危机管理会议上，他们向他汇报了症状，并告诉他这种病毒能阻止人们忧郁。但事情比这更糟。
Mr. Mayor, 82% not only stop brooding. They stop smoking. 93% stop drinking.
市长先生，82%的人不仅不再忧郁，他们还戒了烟。93%的人戒了酒。
What's wrong with that?
那有什么不对吗？
In terms of dollars and cents, it's disastrous. Our city is facing a drastic loss in income from sales tax.
从美元和美分来说，这是灾难性的。我们城市正面临销售税收入的剧烈损失。
That's ridiculous. 47 people? Drop in a bucket.
这太荒谬了。47个人？沧海一粟。
But if this goes unchecked for a month, by mathematical progression, half of New York will have the virus. You know what that means? It means a loss in cigarette and liquor taxes, more than $180 million.
但如果一个月内不加以遏制，按数学级数计算，半个纽约都会感染这种病毒。你知道这意味着什么吗？这意味着香烟和酒税的损失超过 1.8 亿美元。
$180 million? Brady, what are you sitting there for? Get that bird!
1.8 亿美元？布雷迪，你还在那儿坐着干什么？去把那只鸟抓住！
BRADY: Yes, sir!
布雷迪：是的，先生！
Brady is the chief of police. Capture the bird, they can extract its tissues, come up with a cure, and stave off an economic crisis. Because of course, what's the most important thing a politician thinks of in a potential pandemic? How to save the economy.
布雷迪是警察局长。抓住鸟，他们就能提取组织，研制出解药，避免一场经济危机。因为当然，政客在潜在疫情中最先想到的是什么？如何拯救经济。
Meantime, Pete, much to Liz's horror, has shaved off his beard, cut his hair, and is talking about trying to get his old advertising job back. Which, quick digression, interests me because it's the opposite of subversive. Once these nonconformists get infected, instead of dropping out, they drop in.
同时，皮特，令利兹恐惧的是，他刮掉了胡子，剪了头发，还在谈论想找回他以前的广告工作。顺便提一下，这让我很感兴趣，因为它与颠覆性截然相反。一旦这些非主流感染了病毒，他们没有选择退出，而是选择了加入。
Pete feels so good, in fact, that once he figures out what's, quote unquote, "wrong with him," he wants to share it with everyone, starting with Liz. In an age when all of us are actively avoiding each other's bodies like the plague, because of the plague, it's wild to watch someone actively trying to spread of virus like this.
事实上，皮特感觉太好了，一旦他搞清楚了自己身上“出什么问题了”，他就想和每个人分享，从利兹开始。在这样一个因为瘟疫而让所有人像躲避瘟疫一样避开彼此身体的时代，看着有人积极试图传播病毒是多么疯狂啊。
One little kiss and you'll have it, too.
亲我一下，你也会有的。
I don't want it.
我不要。
Just one little kiss. You'll like yourself in the morning.
就亲一下。明天你会喜欢你自己的。
I don't want it, Pete.
我不要，皮特。
We'll get married, a real marriage--
我们会结婚，真正的婚姻——
I don't want it.
我不要。
Chasing her around the room.
他在房间里追着她。
We'll get a little place in Jersey. We'll have some kids and I'll mow the lawn.
我们会在新泽西找个小地方。我们会生几个孩子，我会去修剪草坪。
And give up all this?
然后放弃这一切？
Eventually, in a completely unbelievable moment that would never have survived the MeToo movement, Pete disguises himself as a nihilist German philosopher and tries to pressure Liz into bed, finally settling for a kiss. He exposes the rest of the gang, too. They all shave, cut their hair, Queer Eye their apartments. The Sack climbs out of her sack, and the toucan, remarkably, keeps coming back, becomes their pet. They call him Amigo.
最终，在一个完全不可思议的瞬间——这种事在“我也是”运动之后绝不可能存活——皮特伪装成一个虚无主义的德国哲学家，试图强迫利兹上床，最后以一个吻了事。他也暴露了团伙里的其他人。他们全都刮了脸，剪了头发，把公寓弄得像“粉雄救兵”一样时尚。“麻袋”从她的麻袋里爬了出来，而巨嘴鸟，出人意料地一直回来，成了他们的宠物。他们叫它阿米戈。
There's Amigo.
看，阿米戈。
At the same time, the mayor is bundled off to an emergency bunker, so that he doesn't get sick. A TV reporter buttonholes him on the way in.
同时，市长被送往一个应急掩体，以防生病。一个电视记者在路上拦住了他。
Tell me, sir, is there any truth to the rumor that there's been a spread in the epidemic?
告诉我，先生，有传言说疫情已经扩散，这是真的吗？
Epidemic? Well, I'd hardly call it an epidemic. After all, we only have 180 million-- 47 cases.
疫情？嗯，我很难称之为疫情。毕竟，我们只有 1.8 亿…… 47 例病例。
Well, why then, sir, are you visiting the fallout shelter?
那么，先生，为什么你要访问防空洞呢？
Just a routine inspection last Friday of every month.
只是每个月最后一个星期五的例行检查。
But today is Saturday, sir.
但今天是星期六，先生。
Well, better late than never.
好吧，迟做总比不做好。
It took me watching this scene a few times, trying to figure out why it sounded so familiar. And then I was like, oh yeah.
我看了几次这个场景，才搞清楚为什么它听起来那么耳熟。然后我就想，哦，对了。
At the height of the protests outside the White House, President Trump was moved for a time to the bunker, something that hasn't happened since 9/11.
在白宫外抗议活动的高潮时，特朗普总统有一段时间被转移到了掩体里，这是 9/11 以来从未发生过的事情。
I was there for a tiny, little short period of time, and it was much more for an inspection. There was no--
我在那里待了很短很短的时间，这更多是为了检查。没有什么——
Anyway, there aren't only 47 cases for long. And that is largely due to the efforts of Pete and Liz, and their friends. They wage a campaign to spread the virus intentionally by subterfuge. Liz and the Sack volunteer to hand out masks to their fellow citizens, breathing on them first.
总之，47 例病例没维持多久。这主要归功于皮特、利兹和他们的朋友们的努力。他们通过诡计发起了一场故意传播病毒的运动。利兹和“麻袋”自愿向市民分发口罩，先对着口罩呼气。
While the Sack made sure that every mask was specially treated with the virus, I made sure that nobody got away without one.
当“麻袋”确保每个口罩都经过病毒特殊处理时，我确保没有人能漏掉。
I was in charge of transportation, assisted by Conrad. Our specialty was the subway at rush hour. Where the biggest crowds were breathing in, we were there, breathing out.
我负责运输，康拉德协助我。我们的专长是高峰时段的地铁。在人潮呼吸最密集的地方，我们就出现在那里，呼气。
They breathe on peanuts and feed them to the pigeons. Liz and another friend get jobs as burlesque dancers. Their shtick is blowing soap bubbles into people's faces. And in just a couple of days, the number of cases explodes to about 2 million, about a quarter of the city's population. Cabbies stop in the middle of the street to let pedestrians cross in front of them. Marriage license applications flood city hall, Pete and Liz's among them. Barbershop lines are staggering. People literally dance in the streets with joy. It's a disaster.
他们对着花生呼气，然后喂给鸽子。利兹和另一个朋友在滑稽剧院当舞者。她们的绝活是向人们的脸上吹肥皂泡。仅仅几天，病例数量激增到约 200 万，约为城市人口的四分之一。出租车司机停在街道中间让行人在他们面前走过。市政厅挤满了申请结婚许可的人，其中就有皮特和利兹。理发店的排队人数惊人。人们简直在街上欢快地跳舞。这是一场灾难。
Finally, the president's envoy is helicoptered into New York City to save the day-- and frankly, to save the movie. It's Dom Deluise, from Blazing Saddles, Spaceballs, Robin Hood-- Men In Tights.
最后，总统特使被直升机送往纽约市来拯救世界——坦率地说，是来拯救电影。他是由在《闪亮的马鞍》、《太空炮弹》、《侠盗罗宾汉：英雄也性感》中出演的多姆·德路易斯饰演。
I have a statement from the president.
我有总统的一份声明。
Dom Deluise. I love Dom Deluise. He looms so large in my childhood comedy pantheon. He's atomically funny, even in this very not good film. His character, Jay Gardner Monroe, is way more confident and bossy and conceited than he is capable. He snaps his fingers at his aides. He uses the word "repeat," before repeating himself, like a military general.
多姆·德路易斯。我爱多姆·德路易斯。他在我童年的喜剧殿堂里占据了很大的位置。他非常滑稽，即使是在这部极其糟糕的电影里也是如此。他饰演的角色杰伊·加德纳·门罗，比他能力范围所及要自信、专横、自负得多。他向助手打响指。他使用“重复”这个词，在重复自己之前，就像一位军事将军。
Anyway, he heads straight to the bunker and tells the mayor and everyone that if the toucan isn't caught before the tally reaches 3 million cases, he's putting plan CC-27 into effect.
总之，他径直前往掩体，告诉市长和所有人，如果不在总数达到 300 万之前抓住巨嘴鸟，他将启动 CC-27 计划。
The bridges, tunnels, airports will be closed. Repeat, closed! Not one single person will get in or out of New York.
桥梁、隧道、机场都将关闭。重复，关闭！一个人也不准进出纽约。
But, Mr. Monroe, do you realize we have 52 conventions coming in next week?
但是，门罗先生，您意识到我们下周有 52 场会议要举行吗？
Conventions? Do you realize what would happen if this got to Washington? Republicans agreeing with Democrats and vice versa? This bird could destroy our two party system, the very foundation of our great democracy.
会议？你意识到如果这传到华盛顿会发生什么吗？共和党人同意民主党人，反之亦然？这只鸟可能会摧毁我们的两党制，那是我们伟大民主的根基。
The tally board is at 2.2 million cases at this point. And this is really the final and maybe most alarming parallel between our story and real life. As Monroe watches the numbers tick upward, he shakes his head in disgust.
此时 tally 板上显示 220 万例。这是我们的故事与现实生活之间最终也许是最令人震惊的相似之处。当门罗看着数字向上跳动时，他厌恶地摇了摇头。
Those commies sure are sneaky. Oh, come on. You don't think for one moment that this thing is just an accident, do you? Do you? When that bird landed on that ship, its position was--
那些共产党人真是狡猾。噢，得了吧。你不会有片刻认为这事只是个意外吧？你会吗？当那只鸟降落在船上时，它的位置是——
Longitude 82, latitude 24.
经度 82，纬度 24。
24, not very far from Cuba, eh? Take my word for it, that bird is a hook-nosed missile sent here by You Know Who.
24，离古巴不远，嘿？相信我，那只鸟是你们都知道的那家伙派来的钩鼻导弹。
You know who, Fidel Castro.
你们知道是谁，菲德尔·卡斯特罗。
Look at the facts. When people get the bug, they suddenly love the world. Now, if You Know Who was getting ready to act up again, what would be better than to give Americans a sense of security, a false sense of security and euphoria?
看看事实。当人们得了病，他们突然爱上了这个世界。现在，如果你们知道的那家伙正准备再次捣乱，有什么比给美国人一种安全感——一种虚假的安全感和欣快感——更好的呢？
Mr. Monroe, you're not suggesting this virus was artificially produced in a laboratory?
门罗先生，您不是在暗示这种病毒是实验室人工制造的吧？
Yes, a virus produced-- laboratory, yes.
是的，一种病毒制造的——实验室，是的。
Medical impossibility. Just couldn't have happened.
医学上是不可能的。这根本不可能发生。
Hah. That's what they said about the power failure here in New York in '65.
哈。他们对 65 年纽约的停电也是这么说的。
And what about the Asian flu?
那亚洲流感呢？
That came straight, believe you me, from Red China.
相信我，那直接来自红色中国。
Of course it's satire. And in that way, it's cathartic. But when I got to that scene, it suddenly felt like every other part of the movie had been an escape from what's going on. It's funny that one of the most ludicrous pieces of dialogue is also practically a quote we've heard in the news in 2020, and not as a joke.
这当然是讽刺。从某种意义上说，它有宣泄作用。但当我看到那一幕时，它突然感觉就像电影的其他部分是在逃避正在发生的事情一样。有趣的是，最荒谬的对话之一，实际上也是我们在 2020 年新闻中听到的引语，而且不是作为笑话。
There's so much more of the story left, but just to abridge, they finally managed to isolate the virus. Amazingly, because it's a movie, they develop a vaccine, like, that day. But they still have to test it out, so they spray it in Pete and Liz's nuptial bed, in the hotel room where they're spending their wedding night, and set up a hidden camera behind the air vent.
故事还有很多，但简而言之，他们最终成功分离了病毒。令人惊奇的是，因为它是电影，他们在当天就研制出了疫苗。但他们还得测试它，所以他们把它喷在皮特和利兹的婚床上，在他们度蜜月的酒店房间里，并在通风口后面架设了一个隐藏摄像头。
Everybody in the bunker-- the mayor, the Fauci character, Jay Gardner Monroe, all of them-- sit and monitor the couple on a big screen as morning arrives. Liz wakes up to Pete coming back from an errand. He's still wearing his suit, but he's disheveled, messy hair, smoking.
掩体里的每个人——市长、福奇式人物、杰伊·加德纳·门罗，所有人——坐着观看大屏幕上的这对夫妇，早晨来临。利兹醒来，看到皮特办完事回来。他还是穿着西装，但衣衫不整，头发凌乱，抽着烟。
Good morning, darling. I didn't hear you--
早上好，亲爱的。我没听到你——
Couldn't sleep. Went out for coffee and cigarettes.
睡不着。出去买了咖啡和香烟。
Room service is probably up and I'll order breakfast.
客房服务可能上来了，我去点个早餐。
Don't. I don't want any.
别。我什么也不要。
Oh, but Pete, you really should eat something.
噢，但皮特，你真的应该吃点东西。
Don't bug me!
别烦我！
Jay Gardner Monroe, watching on the monitor from the bunker, is psyched.
在掩体里通过监视器观看的杰伊·加德纳·门罗感到很兴奋。
Well, he's back to normal. It worked, Doc.
嗯，他恢复正常了。有效了，医生。
Not her. She doesn't seem to have changed a bit.
她没变。她看起来一点都没变。
And I don't know what this says about me, but of all the scenes in the movie, this is the one I remember the most clearly from the first time I saw it. I've actually carried it around all of these years, because it's genuinely so sad. Liz looks like her heart is breaking in real time.
我不知道这说明了我什么，但在电影的所有场景中，这是我第一次看时记忆最清晰的一幕。我其实把这一幕记了这么多年，因为它确实太令人难过了。利兹看起来心在实时破碎。
No, don't ask me to go back. Remember what we had. Remember it, cling to it.
不，别让我回去。记住我们拥有过的一切。记住它，紧紧抓住它。
You're kidding yourself. You talk about goodness and kindness. Read the front page and try and find something.
你在自欺欺人。你谈论善良和友爱。读读头版，试着找点什么出来吧。
Pete, I can't go back. I couldn't live that kind of life ever again.
皮特，我回不去了。我再也无法过那种生活了。
Pete shrugs.
皮特耸了耸肩。
OK. You drink your poison, and I'll drink mine.
好吧。你喝你的毒药，我喝我的。
There's no doubt about him. That was certainly a positive reaction.
对他毫无疑问。那肯定是一个积极的反应。
Positive. There's a happy ending. Liz decides to leave New York and move home. But at the very last minute, she goes to say goodbye to Amigo, the bird, who's in a zoo now. And Pete's there, too.
积极。有一个快乐的结局。利兹决定离开纽约回老家。但在最后一分钟，她去和阿米戈告别，那只鸟现在在动物园里。皮特也在那儿。
Liz!
利兹！
They do that rom com running thing.
他们上演了那浪漫喜剧般的奔跑情节。
Pete!
皮特！
And just like that, they're back together. The city spews the vaccine into the air via factory chimneys and exhaust pipes, and most of New York lives miserably ever after. But some people stay pleasant and uplifted, because-- major plot twist-- 50% of the people who seemed to be infected actually never got the virus in the first place. The joy just rubbed off on them, and Liz was one of those people, which is why she didn't get, quote, unquote, "better" in the hotel room. Which is actually the moral of the movie, that happiness is a choice.
就这样，他们又在一起了。这座城市通过工厂烟囱和排气管将疫苗喷向空中，纽约的大多数人从此陷入了悲惨的生活。但有些人保持了愉快和振奋，因为——重大情节转折——50% 看起来被感染的人实际上从未感染病毒。快乐只是感染了他们，而利兹就是其中之一，这就是为什么她在酒店房间里没有“好转”的原因。这实际上是电影的寓意，快乐是一种选择。
But watching the movie during this pandemic, I drew another, darker conclusion. Somehow, that wiggly weird jolt of recognition I got over and over again, what it felt like was, this is how it goes. When faced with a crisis like this, governments will minimize the severity of the danger. They'll value the wrong things. They'll focus on the economy over people's lives, and blame foreigners in an ugly, xenophobic way.
但在疫情期间观看这部电影，我得出了另一个更黑暗的结论。不知何故，那种我一次又一次感受到的那种怪异的认知冲击，感觉就像是，事情就是这样发生的。当面临这样的危机时，政府会把危险程度最小化。他们会重视错误的东西。他们会优先考虑经济而不是人的生命，并以丑陋的仇外方式指责外国人。
I'm sure there's a version of America where all that might not happen, but we're not living in that America right now. And Pete and Liz weren't living in it, either. If it's possible for human beings to do the wrong thing, we'll figure out a way. We're resourceful like that.
我确信有一个版本的美国，这一切可能不会发生，但我们现在并没有生活在那个美国。皮特和利兹也不在那儿。如果人类有可能做错事，我们总能想出办法。我们就是这么有创造力。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
(SINGING) Man, I had the craziest dream. I danced with Mr. Clean and gave the white knight a helping hand.
(演唱) 天哪，我做了个最疯狂的梦。我和清洁先生跳了舞，还帮了白骑士一把。
Coming up, OK, 5 o'clock somewhere, but in Wisconsin, they're asking when it's 5 o'clock here, does that really mean 5 o'clock? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，好吧，虽然某个地方是 5 点，但在威斯康星，他们问当这里是 5 点时，那真的是指 5 点吗？一分钟后见，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Audience of One, stories about people watching movies and watching some other things, too, and seeing something in them that other people do not. We have arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, Late Registration.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“专属观众”，关于人们看电影以及看其他东西的故事，并在其中看到了其他人没看到的东西。我们进入了节目的第二幕——第二幕：迟到的注册。
So vérité political documentaries are not everybody's thing, especially if they are over five hours long and go straight to video. But one of our producers, Ben Calhoun, discovered one that he found pretty mesmerizing. It concerns Kanye West. As you probably know, Kanye West is running for president. He's not on the ballot in enough states to actually win the presidency, but he's in some key battleground states, including Wisconsin.
所以，真实电影风格的政治纪录片不是每个人的菜，尤其是如果它们超过五个小时且直接发行录像带的话。但我们的制片人之一本·卡尔霍恩发现了一部让他觉得非常着迷的纪录片。它关乎坎耶·韦斯特。如你所知，坎耶·韦斯特正在竞选总统。他的选票没有出现在足够多的州来真正赢得总统职位，但他在一些关键的摇摆州，包括威斯康星州。
Of course, a celebrity on the ballot will always siphon off at least some votes. And in Wisconsin, both parties are scrounging for any little pocket of votes that they can get, because as you may recall in 2016, Donald Trump won Wisconsin by just 23,000 votes out of 2.8 million cast. So any tiny wedge votes could possibly make the difference and determine who wins the state this time.
当然，候选人名单上的名人总会至少带走一些选票。而在威斯康星州，两党都在争夺他们能得到的每一张选票，因为你可能记得 2016 年，唐纳德·特朗普以 2.8 万票的优势赢得了威斯康星州，总票数 280 万。所以任何微小的选票都可能产生影响并决定谁赢得该州。
Which brings us to the video Ben saw. Here he is.
这就引出了本看到的视频。他在那里。
This 5 and 1/2 hour video is of the Wisconsin Elections Commission deciding whether Kanye West would get to appear on the state's ballot in November. Wisconsin, my home state, it's like a lot of places. If you're Kanye West or anyone who's not from a major party, you've got to collect a certain number of signatures to get on the ballot. In Kanye West's case, a company flew in canvassers, who started circulating petitions just one day before the signatures would have to be turned in to state elections officials, at 5:00 PM.
这段 5 个半小时的视频是威斯康星州选举委员会决定坎耶·韦斯特是否能出现在 11 月的选票上。威斯康星，我的家乡，和很多地方一样。如果你是坎耶·韦斯特或者任何不是来自主要政党的人，你必须收集一定数量的签名才能出现在选票上。在坎耶·韦斯特的案例中，一家公司雇佣了拉票员，他们在签名必须提交给州选举官员的截止时间——下午 5:00——的前一天才开始散发请愿书。
So they collect and collect. Next day comes, Tuesday, August 4, and we arrive at the deadline, 5:00 PM, a tiny moment cradled between 4:59 and 5:01, a speck on the surface of American history, but one that would spiral out into a marathon political debate.
所以他们不断收集。第二天来了，8 月 4 日，星期二，我们到达了截止时间，下午 5:00，一个夹在 4:59 和 5:01 之间的小小瞬间，美国历史表面上的一个斑点，但它却演变成了一场马拉松式的政治辩论。
My name is Ann Jacobs. I'm chair of the Wisconsin Elections Commission. We are here for a special meeting.
我叫安·雅各布斯。我是威斯康星州选举委员会主席。我们在这里举行特别会议。
Here we are a couple of weeks later. It's Thursday afternoon. The Wisconsin Elections Commission gets together to decide about kicking Kanye West off the Wisconsin ballot. The setting is one that's familiar to a lot of people now, Zoom.
我们来到两周后。那是星期四下午。威斯康星州选举委员会聚在一起决定是否将坎耶·韦斯特踢出威斯康星选票。场景是现在许多人都很熟悉的：Zoom。
Commissioner Spindell.
斯平德尔委员。
Here.
在。
Commissioner Thomsen.
汤姆森委员。
Here.
在。
The camera toggles between the six commissioners. There's three Republicans, three Democrats. Occasionally, it flips to some of the staff. Running the show, Ann Jacobs, the commission chair, a Democrat. Jacobs gets right down to business-- challenge to West's petitions. There will be a lawyer on each side. So first up, representing the challengers, the folks trying to bump West off the ballot, there's a lawyer named Jeff Mandell. And he looks a little like a young Jon Favreau-- the actor, not the podcaster.
摄像机在六名委员之间切换。有三名共和党人，三名民主党人。偶尔，它会切换到一些工作人员身上。主持会议的是安·雅各布斯，委员会主席，民主党人。雅各布斯直接进入正题——对韦斯特请愿书的质疑。每一方都会有一名律师。首先，代表挑战方，也就是那些试图把韦斯特挤出选票的人，有一位名叫杰夫·曼德尔的律师。他看起来有点像年轻的乔恩·费儒——那个演员，而不是播客主持人。
Mandell appears in what looks like a cozy spot in his house.
曼德尔出现在他家里一个看起来很舒适的地方。
Go ahead.
请开始。
Thank you very much. May it please the Commission, the nomination papers submitted on behalf of Mr. West and Miss Tidball were untimely. They were filed after 5:00 PM. Statute 8.20, subdivision 8, section 8 AM says that nomination papers must be filed not later than 5:00 PM.
非常感谢。委员会，请允许我说明，代表韦斯特先生和蒂德博尔小姐提交的提名文件是不合时的。它们是在下午 5:00 之后提交的。法规 8.20，第 8 子项，第 8 AM 节规定，提名文件必须不晚于下午 5:00 提交。
That is very legal way to say, West was late. An attorney for his campaign, a woman named Lane Ruhland, she rolled up to the building in an SUV moments before 5:00. She shuffled papers around on her dashboard and then rushed in, as a TV news crew filmed her. And Mandell lays all of this out with the punch and swagger of a prosecutor on a capital murder case, when really he's just talking about a lawyer walking through a door.
那是说韦斯特迟到的非常法律的方式。他的竞选律师，一个名叫莱恩·鲁兰的女人，在 5 点前几分钟开着 SUV 赶到了大楼。她在仪表盘上摆弄文件，然后冲了进去，当时有电视新闻摄制组在拍摄她。曼德尔带着资本谋杀案检察官的那种力度和狂妄陈述了这一切，而事实上他只是在谈论一个律师走进了一扇门。
By her own admission, Attorney Ruhland was in her car at 4:59 PM. That's in paragraph 6 of her affidavit on page 928 of the commission materials. Miss Ruhland exited her car a couple of seconds after 5 o'clock. You can see that in exhibit A to the Remiker affidavit at three minutes and four seconds in the video.
鲁兰律师自己承认，她在下午 4:59 在车里。这在委员会材料第 928 页她的宣誓书第 6 段中。鲁兰小姐在 5 点过几秒后下车。你可以在 Remiker 宣誓书的附件 A 中看到，视频时间在 3 分 04 秒处。
What follows is a Zapruder film style reconstruction of this whole scene at the front door of the Wisconsin Elections Commission, the moment when West's lawyer rushed in with the petitions. Mandell has stitched all this together from affidavits of a TV news story and a video from a Democratic Party operative, who filmed all this, including a shot of his Apple watch for a timestamp.
接下来是威斯康星州选举委员会前门整个场景的“扎普鲁德电影”风格重现，韦斯特的律师带着请愿书冲进来的那一刻。曼德尔把这一切从电视新闻故事的宣誓书和民主党特工的视频中拼凑起来，特工拍摄了这一切，包括他那块带时间戳的苹果手表的镜头。
Miss Ruhland entered the building no earlier than 14 seconds after 5 o'clock. Her colleague followed eight or nine seconds later with the bulk of the papers. That left them no more than 36 seconds to walk the length of the first floor, to wait for the elevator, to ride to the third floor, to wait for the doors to open, to walk to the main desk of the commission, and to transfer the papers to the filing officer.
鲁兰小姐进入大楼的时间不早于 5 点 14 秒。她的同事八九秒后带着大部分文件跟进。这留给他们的时间不超过 36 秒，走完一楼，等电梯，乘到三楼，等门打开，走到委员会的主办公桌，并将文件移交给归档官员。
That cannot happen in 37 seconds. The staff memo reaches that conclusion on page 15. The papers were in the elevator and not in the filing clerk's possession at 5:01.
那在 37 秒内是不可能发生的。工作人员备忘录在第 15 页得出了这一结论。文件在电梯里，而不在归档文员手中，是在 5:01。
Maybe you've seen stories about how Republican fingerprints are all over Kanye West's nebulous presidential campaign. There was no attempt to hide them in Wisconsin. The company that hired the canvassers, who got West's signatures, it's reportedly run by a Republican operative. It did the same thing for him in Ohio, West Virginia, Arkansas.
也许你看到过关于共和党如何把指纹印在坎耶·韦斯特模糊的总统竞选活动上的报道。在威斯康星州，他们没有试图隐藏。雇佣拉票员并获得韦斯特签名的人的公司，据说由一名共和党特工经营。它在俄亥俄州、西弗吉尼亚州、阿肯色州也为他做了同样的事。
Lane Ruhland, the lawyer who dropped off his petitions in Wisconsin, she used to work for former Republican governor Scott Walker and the Republican Party of Wisconsin. She recently represented the Trump campaign in a lawsuit.
莱恩·鲁兰，在威斯康星提交请愿书的律师，她曾经为前共和党州长斯科特·沃克和威斯康星州共和党工作。她最近代表特朗普竞选团队处理了一起诉讼。
When the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel dug into who was listed on West's paperwork, it found one Republican activist and operative after another. Black officials in Milwaukee have accused Republicans of helping West's candidacy as a cynical and insulting attempt to divert Black voters away from Joe Biden to aid Donald Trump.
当密尔沃基哨兵报挖掘谁的名字列在韦斯特的文件上时，发现了一位又一位共和党活动家和特工。密尔沃基的黑人官员指责共和党人协助韦斯特的候选资格，这是将黑人选民从乔·拜登那里转移开以帮助唐纳德·特朗普的一种愤世嫉俗和侮辱性的企图。
Wisconsin Republicans haven't admitted that. They've also conspicuously not denied it. Asked about the Republican attorney who submitted West's paperwork, a GOP spokeswoman told the newspaper, quote, "it appears that Kanye West made a smart decision by hiring an experienced election attorney."
威斯康星共和党人没有承认这一点。他们也明显没有否认。当被问及提交韦斯特文件的共和党律师时，一位共和党女发言人告诉报纸，引用：“看起来坎耶·韦斯特聘请了一位经验丰富的选举律师，做出了一个明智的决定。”
Back to the meeting. The attorney trying to knock West off the ballot goes through several other problems with West's petitions, and then it's time for the 10 minute response from the West campaign.
回到会议。试图把韦斯特挤出选票的律师还列举了韦斯特请愿书的其他几个问题，然后是韦斯特竞选团队 10 分钟的回复时间。
You may begin your time to argue.
你可以开始你的辩论时间了。
All right, thank you. Good afternoon, Madam Chair, Elections Commission staff, and opposing counsel.
好的，谢谢。下午好，主席女士，选举委员会工作人员，以及对方律师。
Representing the West campaign is not the lawyer who filed the petitions, but a lawyer named Michael Curran. He looks unnervingly like billionaire Mark Cuban, and he appears unfortunately backlit, his face shaded and kind of hard to see. When he gets started, Attorney Curran makes what I suppose is the argument that he has to make, that walking in 14 seconds past the 5 o'clock deadline, that's not actually late.
代表韦斯特竞选团队的不是提交请愿书的律师，而是一位名叫迈克尔·柯伦的律师。他看起来很不自然地像亿万富翁马克·库班，而且不幸的是他背后有光，他的脸被阴影遮住，很难看清。当他开始发言时，柯伦律师提出了我想他必须提出的论点：走进 5 点过后 14 秒，那实际上并不晚。
When we're talking about time periods, no later than includes the time frame and the reference that were used. For example, "no later than Tuesday" does not mean prior to Tuesday. "No later than Tuesday" means all of Tuesday. And to make 5:00 PM, quote, unquote, "late," the proper language would be "before 5:00 PM" or "prior to 5:00 PM" or "not later than 4:59 PM." But "no later than 5:00 PM" does include the full minute.
当我们谈论时间段时，“不晚于”包括了所使用的框架和参考。例如，“不晚于星期二”并不意味着在星期二之前。“不晚于星期二”意味着整个星期二。为了使下午 5:00 成为所谓的“迟到”，正确的语言应该是“下午 5:00 之前”或“下午 5:00 之前”或“不晚于下午 4:59”。但“不晚于下午 5:00”确实包含了完整的一分钟。
The question the West lawyer is posing, is 5 o'clock a point in time, or is 5 o'clock all the space between 4:59 and 5:01? It's not actually such a bad question. Like. April 15 is the tax deadline. You get all day on the 15th to file, right?
韦斯特律师提出的问题是，5 点是一个时间点，还是 5 点是 4:59 到 5:01 之间的所有空间？这不是一个坏问题。比如。4 月 15 日是报税截止日期。你在 15 号当天全天都可以申报，对吧？
The next plot twist happens when the first Republican takes his turn asking questions of the two lawyers. That's a Republican named Dean Knudson. He's a former state lawmaker. He's a veterinarian. Knudson's sitting in front of this folksy painting that makes it feel like he might be in the waiting room of his veterinary practice, and he's noticeably skeptical of the West campaign's attorney.
下一个情节转折发生在第一位共和党人轮到向两位律师提问时。那是一位名叫迪恩·努德森的共和党人。他是前州立法委员。他是名兽医。努德森坐在那幅充满乡土气息的画前，让人感觉他可能在他的兽医诊所候诊室里，他明显对韦斯特竞选团队的律师持怀疑态度。
5 o'clock is 5 o'clock. So I understand you're trying to make an argument that 5 o'clock is 5:01, but it just seems to me that everything that starts with a 4 is before 5 o'clock, and 5 o'clock's the deadline. Maybe I'm just common sense and not a lawyer, but that's the way it seems.
5 点就是 5 点。所以我明白你试图辩解说 5 点是 5:01，但在我看来，所有以 4 开头的时间都在 5 点之前，而 5 点就是截止日期。也许我只是有常识而没有法律头脑，但看起来就是这样。
Attorney Curran, if you set a timer on your phone to go off at 5 o'clock, when would it go off?
柯伦律师，如果你在手机上设了一个 5 点响的闹钟，它会在什么时候响？
It should go off at 5 o'clock sharp, as soon as the clock turned to 5:00.
它应该在 5 点整响起，当时钟转到 5:00 的那一刻。
Five, zero, zero, zero, zero, so on.
五、零、零、零、零，以此类推。
Yes.
是的。
So if we had set a timer to go off at 5:00, would the papers have been in on time or not?
那么如果我们设定了一个 5:00 响的闹钟，文件是按时送达的还是没有？
Well, the first response would be, that's for the filing officer to determine. But to answer your question directly--
嗯，第一反应是，那要由归档官员来决定。但直接回答你的问题——
But if Knudson doesn't seem to be toeing the party line, the next Republican commissioner to ask questions, he seems more than ready to do the opposite.
但如果努德森看起来不像是要遵守党派路线，下一位提问的共和党委员看起来更像是准备做相反的事情。
Commissioner Spindell, it's your floor.
斯平德尔委员，轮到你了。
OK, thank you.
好的，谢谢。
On camera, Commissioner Robert Spindell. He looks like he's being held captive in a supply room somewhere. He's against this white wall that has nothing on it. Pretty quickly, he goes really big on the West campaign's argument that 5 o'clock means you have right up until 5:01.
镜头前，罗伯特·斯平德尔委员。他看起来像是在什么地方的储藏室里被软禁了。他面对着那面白墙，上面什么都没有。很快，他非常支持韦斯特竞选团队关于 5 点意味着你可以一直到 5:01 的论点。
On your point about, is 5 o'clock 5 o'clock, I did a lot of time trying to plan something, and there's no real definitive action.
关于你的观点，5 点就是 5 点，我花了很多时间试图计划某事，没有什么真正明确的行动。
Over the next few minutes, Spindell makes a number of creative arguments, trying to help the Kanye West lawyer. Like he says, since the petitions entered the building at 5 o'clock and 14 seconds, well, 14 seconds is less than half a minute, so that really rounds back down to 5:00 PM sharp, right?
在接下来的几分钟里，斯平德尔提出了许多有创造性的论点，试图帮助坎耶·韦斯特的律师。比如他说，因为请愿书是在 5 点 14 秒进入大楼的，嗯，14 秒少于半分钟，所以这真的应该四舍五入回下午 5:00 整，对吧？
I mean, that's just simply math in rounding type errors.
我的意思是，这在舍入误差方面就是简单的数学。
Spindell also questions whether the West campaign team actually had to turn in the petitions in order for the petitions to be turned in.
斯平德尔还质疑韦斯特竞选团队是否真的必须提交请愿书才能算提交了请愿书。
And as I understand, she and her assistant got on the elevator with a staff person, just the three of them. Would you not consider that that could be transfer of documents at that time? That once the door closed to the elevator--
据我了解，她和她的助手与一名工作人员一起上了电梯，只有他们三个人。你难道不认为在那时就已经可以算作文件的转移了吗？一旦电梯门关上——
To be clear, Spindell is contending that being in the elevator with a staff member and not handing the staff member the documents is the same as being in the office and physically turning them in. Can I say, there's something about how the action of all this plays out on Zoom, with all the normal Zoomy interruptions. It feels intimate. One commissioner keeps dropping off the call. At one point, there's a cat butt that pops into a frame next to a commissioner asking questions. And also, when people go at each other, it feels more personal somehow, because you just see them, and they're in their homes.
明确地说，斯平德尔认为和一名工作人员在电梯里，而不是把文件递给工作人员，就等同于在办公室里身体力行地提交文件。我可以这么说，所有这一切在 Zoom 上上演的方式，伴随着所有正常的 Zoom 式中断，有某种东西。它感觉很亲密。一位委员不断掉线。在某一时刻，一位提问的委员旁边出现了一个猫屁股。而且，当人们互相攻击时，它在某种程度上感觉更个人化了，因为你只是看着他们，而他们就在家里。
Like Ann Jacobs, the chair-- a few times, she gets into it with Spindell. And you see her in what I think is her living room. She's wearing pearls, and she's sitting in front of a fireplace and what looks like a silver tea set. So it's way less like a debate in some random government building or whatever, and more like family members getting in a fight on the phone or something.
就像主席安·雅各布斯——几次，她和斯平德尔发生了争执。你看到她在我认为是她的客厅里。她戴着珍珠项链，坐在壁炉和看起来像一套银质茶具的前面。所以这远不像在某个随意的政府大楼里的辩论，更像是家人在电话里吵架之类的。
I'd like to make a friendly amendment. Can I do that? You don't have to take it, obviously, but I'd like to make a friendly motion that we substitute the motion that we already passed.
我想做一个友好的修正。我可以这样做吗？你不必接受，显然，但我希望提出一个友好的动议，即我们替代我们已经通过的动议。
Just wait a minute, Bob!
等一分钟，鲍勃！
I thought you said I could. I'm sorry.
我以为你说我可以。对不起。
No!
不！
OK.
好的。
Just wait.
等着。
But I still haven't gotten to the most memorable parts of Spindell's speechifying. They started when he talked about COVID.
但我还没讲到斯平德尔演说中最令人难忘的部分。当他谈到新冠时，它们就开始了。
Curran, would you agree that the pandemic has made life and everything else much harder?
柯伦，你会同意大流行让生活和一切都变得更加困难吗？
Yes.
是的。
In a situation like this, where the pandemic makes things harder, and where everything else is-- there's great efforts in the election process to try and make the procedure easier for all voters, then would you agree that we should try and make it a little bit easier--
在这样一种情况下，大流行让事情变得更难，而在其他一切方面——选举过程中有巨大的努力试图让所有选民的程序变得更容易，那么你会同意我们应该试图让它变得更容易一点吗——
Spindell's essentially making an argument that democracy takes more time during a pandemic, and so people should get more time to do things. Which, let's just pause Spindell for a second here, because the Wisconsin GOP has systematically staked out positions to do the opposite.
斯平德尔本质上是在论证大流行期间民主需要更多时间，所以人们应该有更多时间去做事。让我们在这里暂停一下斯平德尔，因为威斯康星共和党一直在系统地采取相反的立场。
This year, Wisconsin conservatives have fought the idea of giving more time for early voting and absentee voting. In April, Republicans also made it very clear that they opposed postponing an election due to COVID, including Robert Spindell, who said COVID was no reason to postpone an election. Still, Spindell had one more argument.
今年，威斯康星保守派一直在反对给予更多时间进行提前投票和缺席投票。4 月份，共和党人也非常明确地表示，他们反对因新冠推迟选举，包括罗伯特·斯平德尔，他说新冠不是推迟选举的理由。尽管如此，斯平德尔还有一个论点。
Wisconsin Democrats, which is the people that are bringing this challenge-- my question is, when are they gonna stop suppressing the Black vote? Here, they wish to take away from the Black population an opportunity to take a Black presidential candidate off the ballot and have a choice in terms of who they want to vote for. You know, what's next, in terms of trying to suppress the Black choice?
威斯康星民主党人，也就是提出这一挑战的人——我的问题是，他们什么时候才会停止压制黑人选票？在这里，他们希望剥夺黑人人口将一名黑人总统候选人从选票上除名并拥有他们想投票的人的选择的机会。你知道，在试图压制黑人选择方面，接下来会发生什么？
This is where the meeting truly bent my mind, as if it would make sense for Democrats to suppress Black voters. Nationally, 87% of them identify as Democrats. I couldn't help but think, watching this, that here we are in the throes of this seismic election cycle, one in which lots of people on both sides argue that the people on the other side, they're out to destroy the country. It feels huge.
这就是会议真正让我感到震惊的地方，如果民主党压制黑人选民有意义的话。在全国范围内，87% 的黑人认同自己是民主党人。我看着这一幕，不禁想到，我们正处于这个地震般的选举周期的阵痛中，在这个周期中，双方的许多人都争辩说另一方的人正在摧毁国家。感觉太大了。
It's weird to think that the legitimacy of the election process over the coming weeks will hinge on what happens in so many rooms like this, on tiny screens like this, with public servants and volunteers, and campaign workers who will be wrestling over rules, and deadlines, and signatures, and postmarks.
想到未来几周选举过程的合法性将取决于像这样在许多房间里、像这样在小屏幕上发生的事情，会有公共服务人员和志愿者，还有竞选工作人员将在规则、截止日期、签名和邮戳上纠结，这真是太怪了。
This video, it's actually kind of a sneak preview. And honestly, I think we'll be lucky if it looks like this meeting. Absurd as it got at times, I respect this so much. These commissioners are paid a little over $100 a meeting. They have to read hundreds of pages of documents to prepare for this. And they went around, and around, and around, splitting this 14 second hair every which way.
这段视频，它实际上有点像先睹为快。老实说，我认为如果它看起来像这次会议，我们会很幸运。尽管有时它变得很荒谬，但我非常尊重这一点。这些委员每场会议的报酬略高于 100 美元。他们必须阅读数百页的文件来为会议做准备。他们反复讨论，用各种方式来分割这 14 秒的头发。
For the vast majority of the time, people were thoughtful, and they were willing to step across party lines, if that's what they had to do to get to what they thought was fair. Mostly, they seemed like they were trying to do what was right. And in the end, a very simple argument won out. There was precedent, lots of it.
在绝大多数时间里，人们都很体贴，如果那是他们为了达到他们认为公平的目的所必须做的，他们愿意跨越党派界限。大多数时候，他们看起来像是在试图做正确的事情。最后，一个非常简单的论点获胜了。有先例，有很多。
Many people had missed deadlines in the past, and whether by a lot or a little, they just couldn't accept it.
过去很多人都错过截止日期，无论错过得多还是少，他们就是无法接受。
I vote, aye, the motion is carried five to one.
我投赞成票，动议以五比一通过。
And just like that, Kanye West was off the Wisconsin ballot. The remainder of this video is worth mentioning. If you'll just give me one more minute here, I'll sum it up for you. While Kanye West's campaign made the headlines the next day, the Wisconsin Elections Commission also made another decision that night, one with the power to affect the outcome of the presidential race.
就这样，坎耶·韦斯特被踢出了威斯康星州的选票。这段视频的其余部分值得一提。如果你再给我一分钟，我会为你总结一下。虽然坎耶·韦斯特的竞选活动第二天上了头条，但威斯康星州选举委员会当晚还做了另一个决定，一个有能力影响总统竞选结果的决定。
Also on the agenda that evening was a challenge seeking to bump the Green Party candidates off the ballot on something that's really pretty technical. See, during Wisconsin's signature collection period, the VP candidate for the Green Party seems to have moved. So her address at the beginning, it doesn't match her paperwork at the end.
当晚的议程上还有一项挑战，试图将绿党候选人挤出选票，原因其实相当技术性。你看，在威斯康星州的签名收集期间，绿党副总统候选人似乎搬家了。所以她开头的地址与她结尾的文件不符。
Republicans were like, that's nit-picky BS. But the Democrats wouldn't budge. And the end result? The Green Party was gone, just like West, removed from the ballot. And you don't have to look far to see the enormous stakes of that decision. You remember how in 2016, Donald Trump won Wisconsin by 23,000 votes. That year, the Green Party candidate, Jill Stein, she got 31,000 votes in Wisconsin.
共和党人觉得那是吹毛求疵的废话。但民主党人不肯让步。最终结果呢？绿党就像韦斯特一样消失了，被从选票中除名。你不需要看太远就能看到那个决定的巨大代价。你记得 2016 年唐纳德·特朗普以 2.3 万票赢得了威斯康星州吗？那一年，绿党候选人吉尔·斯坦在威斯康星州获得了 3.1 万张选票。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
After this meeting, the Kanye West Campaign and the Green Party candidates both sued the Wisconsin Elections Commission trying to get on the ballot. The Green Party went to the State Supreme Court and lost-- so no Green Party. In the Kanye West campaign's lawsuit, a judge also ruled no. Judge John Zakowski gave the final word on this debate over the meaning of time in the written decision, quote, "The court believes at the time a grandfather clock rings out 5 times is the moment it is 5 p.m. The court used the analogy of midnight. There is significant difference between 11:59:59 p.m. and one second after midnight. The passage of a second after midnight confers an entirely new day." In other words, quote: "The court finds that, basically, 5 o'clock is 5 o'clock."
这次会议后，坎耶·韦斯特竞选团队和绿党候选人都起诉了威斯康星州选举委员会，试图出现在选票上。绿党去了州最高法院并败诉——所以没有绿党。在坎耶·韦斯特竞选团队的诉讼中，法官也做出了否定的裁决。约翰·扎科夫斯基法官在书面判决中对关于时间的含义的辩论给出了最终裁决，引用：“法院认为，当大笨钟响 5 次的时候，就是下午 5 点的那一刻。法院使用了午夜的类比。晚上 11:59:59 和午夜过后一秒之间有显著差异。午夜后过了一秒就赋予了全新的一天。”换句话说，引用：“法院发现，基本上，5 点就是 5 点。”
Act Three-- Many a Thing She Ought to Understand.
第三幕——她应该理解的许多事情。
One of our producers, Diane Wu, spent most of her life thinking that she did not have a unique and personal take on the film The Sound of Music. The Sound of Music-- after all, everybody loves it. What's there to say? And then she learned, no, her take is very different.
我们的制片人之一黛安·吴，一生中大部分时间都认为她对电影《音乐之声》没有独特且个人的见解。《音乐之声》——毕竟，每个人都喜欢它。有什么可说的？然后她发现，不，她的观点非常不同。
I watched The Sound of Music all the time as a kid. It was one of maybe six VHS tapes we had at home, along with Bambi and 101 Dalmatians. And a few years ago, I was talking with a friend about how much I loved the movie growing up. And he said, "Me too, though the Nazis scared me." And I said, "What Nazis?"
小时候，我总是看《音乐之声》。它是我们在家里的六盘录像带之一，还有《小鹿斑比》和《101忠狗》。几年前，我和一个朋友聊起我从小有多喜欢这部电影。他说：“我也是，虽然纳粹让我害怕。”我说：“什么纳粹？”
And that's when I learned I'd never seen the second half of the film. It turns out, the movie came out in a two VHS box set. And I, for some reason, had only ever seen the first tape. My dad doesn't remember a second tape, either. And why would you need one? The first half makes perfect sense on its own. Here's the plot.
就在那时我才知道我从来没看过电影的后半部分。原来，这部电影是一套双盘录像带。由于某种原因，我只看过第一盘。我爸爸也不记得有第二盘。而且你为什么需要一盘呢？前半部分本身就完全讲得通。剧情是这样的。
It's a movie about a woman named Maria, who is sent to the countryside to babysit a giant family of children with a mean dad, the von Trapps. Maria shows up, bubbly, fun, and teaches them to sing, and play, and be kids, all against the wishes of their father.
这是一部关于一个名叫玛丽亚的妇女的电影，她被送到乡下照顾一个有严厉父亲的庞大家庭——冯·特拉普一家。玛丽亚出现了，活泼、有趣，并教他们唱歌、玩耍、成为孩子，所有这些都违背了他们父亲的意愿。
But the singing wins him over. They sing together as a family. And finally, at a party, the kids sing a beautiful song for the guests. Farewell. And after that, Maria, having successfully fixed the family, leaves, just like Mary Poppins did when she fixed that family. And that's the end of the movie.
但歌声打动了他。他们像一家人一样在一起唱歌。最后，在一次派对上，孩子们为客人们唱了一首优美的歌。告别。此后，玛丽亚在成功修复了这个家庭后离开了，就像玛丽·波平斯修复那个家庭一样。这就是电影的结尾。
I had very clear, fond memories of the goatherd puppet show, and the scene in the gazebo where Liesl, the oldest daughter, secretly met with the mailman she was in love with. And they sang and danced, and it was so romantic. I had no further questions about any of the characters.
对于牧羊人的木偶戏，以及长女莉塞尔与她爱上的邮递员私下在凉亭会面的场景，我有着非常清晰且美好的记忆。他们唱歌跳舞，非常浪漫。我对任何角色都没有进一步的问题。
So when I learned that there were 70 more minutes to the film, I didn't bother going to look for them. The Sound of Music was a full, complete, and wonderful artifact from my childhood. I didn't want to taint it with Nazis.
所以当我得知电影还有 70 分钟时，我没费心去寻找它们。《音乐之声》是我童年时代一个完整、全面且美妙的文物。我不想用纳粹来玷污它。
But when my co-worker Lina, who's producing this week's show and is a musical theater fan, which I most definitely am not-- when she found out I still hadn't seen the whole thing, it seemed heretical to her. She couldn't let it stand.
但是当我的同事莉娜——她是本周节目的制片人，也是音乐剧迷，我绝对不是——发现我还没看过完整版时，她觉得这是异端邪说。她无法容忍这一点。
So we watched it together over the internet one Sunday afternoon, and I prepared to have a childhood memory either slightly enhanced or completely ruined. Before we started, she had me predict what was gonna be in the second half.
所以我们在一个周日下午一起在网上看了这部电影，我准备好让童年的记忆要么略有增强，要么彻底毁灭。在开始之前，她让我预测后半部分会是什么。
I want-- and this is based on my childhood memory and just what I would like to see, is the second half is just focused on my favorite two characters, Liesl and the hot mailman. I want to see their courtship, and then they get married, and that's the end of the movie.
我希望——这是基于我童年的记忆以及我想要看到的东西——后半部分只是专注于我最喜欢的两个角色，莉塞尔和那位帅气的邮递员。我想看到他们的追求，然后他们结婚，这就是电影的结尾。
We hit play and started at the very beginning, started with the part I know. And the first half was more or less the simple, sunny movie I remembered. Seeing the kindly and dour nuns come on screen early on was like recognizing teachers I had in elementary school.
我们按下播放键，从头开始，从我熟悉的部分开始。前半部分或多或少是我记忆中那部简单、阳光的电影。看到善良而严厉的修女们出现在屏幕上，就像认出我在小学时的老师。
Reverend Mother.
院长修女。
Sister Bernice.
伯尼斯修女。
I simply cannot find her.
我根本找不到她。
Maria?
玛丽亚？
There is that gazebo scene, when the mailman and Liesl sing to each other.
有那个凉亭场景，当邮递员和莉塞尔互相唱歌时。
(SINGING) I am 16, going on 17. I know that I'm naive.
(演唱) 我 16 岁，快 17 岁了。我知道我很天真。
Then whirl around the gazebo, dancing.
然后绕着凉亭旋转、跳舞。
Oh my god, this still looks like so much fun.
噢，天哪，这看起来依然太有趣了。
Watching now, though, I saw a lot of things that I had completely missed as a kid. Because as a child, I had apparently ignored anything that adults who were not Maria said to each other. Literally none of that dialogue registered. It was like the mumbly grown-ups in Charlie Brown. My kid self had edited full characters out of the film. I barely remembered the baroness, who wants to marry the dad.
现在看的时候，我看到了很多小时候完全错过的东西。因为作为孩子，我显然忽略了除了玛丽亚之外的成年人对彼此说的任何话。那些对话简直一句都没注册。就像《查理布朗》里那些嘟嘟囔囔的成年人。我童年的自我已经把完整的角色从电影中删除了。我几乎不记得那个想嫁给父亲的男爵夫人。
This really is exciting for me, Georg, being here with you.
这对我和你在一起，乔治，真的很让人兴奋。
Oh, trees, lakes, mountains. When you've seen one, you've seen them all.
噢，树木、湖泊、山脉。当你见过一个，你就都见过了。
That is not what I mean, and you know it.
我不是那个意思，你知道的。
So any of their plot lines that were not resolved in the first half, moot. I also missed, of course, how Maria and the dad supposedly fall in love. The dad, by the way, was even meaner than I remembered, just cruel to Maria.
所以他们任何没在前半部分解决的情节线，都没意义。我当然也错过了玛丽亚和父亲是如何相爱的。顺便说一句，父亲比我记忆中更严厉，对玛丽亚简直残忍。
Turn around, please.
请转过来。
What?
什么？
Turn. Hat off. It's the dress. You'll have to put on another one before you meet the children.
转过来。帽子摘掉。就是那件衣服。在你见到孩子们之前，你得换上一件别的。
But I don't have another one.
但我没有别的衣服。
Because of that, I still had a lot of trouble squaring the idea that anything between the two of them was remotely romantic.
正因如此，我依然很难接受他们俩之间会有任何浪漫的关系。
He thinks he's in love with you.
他认为他爱上你了。
But that's not true.
但这不是真的。
Oh, they really spell it out.
噢，他们真的说出来了。
Yeah, buddy. You missed kind of a lot.
是啊，伙计。你错过了相当多东西。
Surely you've noticed the way he looks into your eyes. And you know, you blushed in his arms when you were dancing just now.
你肯定注意到了他看你眼睛的方式。而且你知道，刚才跳舞时你在他怀里脸红了。
The one romance that still sparkled was between Liesl and the mailman. Though, watching again, I have to say, the mailman was not as cute as I remembered.
唯一依然闪耀的浪漫是在莉塞尔和邮递员之间。不过，重看时，我不得不说，邮递员不像我记忆中那么可爱。
It's the mailman! Oh, he kind of looks like a Nazi.
是邮递员！噢，他看起来有点像纳粹。
Rolfe, the mailman, comes back later in the first half to throw rocks on Liesl's window. That moment I remember. Again, so dreamy. But the one that followed was completely over my head as a kid.
罗尔夫，邮递员，后来在前半部分又回来往莉塞尔的窗户上扔石头。那一刻我记得。再次感叹，太梦幻了。但随后的那一刻小时候完全没听懂。
I didn't see. I mean, I didn't know you were-- Heil Hitler!
我没看见。我是说，我不知道你…… 希特勒万岁！
Oh, heil Hitler?
噢，希特勒万岁？
Yeah, "Heil Hitler." The hero of my version of The Sound of Music, who I'd hoped the second half would center around, he was the Nazi. Also, not the mailman. Yes, he was wearing a uniform and delivering messages, but he was not employed by the postal service, as my child self had understood. He was some kind of military messenger.
是啊，“希特勒万岁”。我那版《音乐之声》的英雄，我本希望后半部分能聚焦于他，他竟然是纳粹。而且不是邮递员。是的，他穿着制服递送信息，但他不是像我小时候理解的那样受雇于邮局。他是一种军事信使。
The first half is peppered with a few more hints like this, that things are gonna take a turn, historically, in the second half of the movie. Uneasy talk about Austrian flags and something called an Anschluss, but all against the backdrop of a glamorous party. They're kind of easy to miss, if you're seven.
前半部分还点缀着一些类似这样的暗示，事情在电影后半部分会在历史意义上发生转折。关于奥地利旗帜和所谓的“德奥合并”的不安谈话，但都是以华丽的派对为背景。如果你七岁的话，这些很容易错过。
The last thing I missed as a kid? The big title card that says intermission in yellow script, that comes onscreen after Maria closes the door. Maybe it was on the second VHS. Lina and I fast forward through the music at intermission, and the second half starts.
小时候我错过的最后一件事？那个在玛丽亚关上门后出现在屏幕上的黄色脚本写的“中场休息”大标题。也许它在第二盘录像带上。莉娜和我快进了中场休息的音乐，后半部分开始了。
Oh my god, Lina. I can't believe--
噢，天哪，莉娜。我不敢相信——
This is like a second movie for you. This is really weird, you haven't seen any of this.
这对你来说就像第二部电影。这真奇怪，你一点都没看过。
Five, six, seven--
五、六、七——
Except as the second half starts, I suddenly feel like I have seen all of this. Watching the children play ball in their backyard felt strangely familiar. I'd spent so much time already with the von Trapps at their home that this new scene just felt like part of my memories.
除了后半部分开始时，我突然觉得我好像看过这一切。看着孩子们在后院踢球感觉很眼熟。我已经和冯·特拉普一家在他们家待了那么久，这一新场景感觉就像我记忆的一部分。
This confusing deja vu sticks with me all the way through the scenes of Maria back at the abbey. It's not until the dad goes to meet Maria at the gazebo and declare his love for her that I am certain I have never seen this before.
这种令人困惑的“似曾相识”一直伴随着我看完玛丽亚回到修道院的所有场景。直到父亲去凉亭见玛丽亚并向她宣布爱意时，我才确定我以前从未看过这个。
Do you know when I first started loving you? That night at the dinner table when you sat on that ridiculous pine cone.
你知道我什么时候开始爱你的吗？那天晚上在餐桌旁，当你坐在那个荒谬的松果上时。
What? I knew the first time you blew that silly whistle.
什么？在你吹那个愚蠢的哨子时，我就知道那是第一次。
Oh my god.
噢，天哪。
Oh, my love.
噢，我的爱人。
This is so gross.
这太恶心了。
They basically just stared at each other three times, and now Maria was letting this horrible man marry her? I could not believe it. Just as I'm settling into the newness of the second half, gawking at Maria's wedding dress, everything in the movie shifts. The Nazis roll into town. It's incredibly abrupt, a cut from literal wedding bells to a bell tolling over a giant swastika flag on the town square. Lines of soldiers march across the plaza ominously. The colors seem to drain out of the movie. The children show up next in drab brown clothes against the stony backdrop, instead of their perky curtain outfits from the first half.
他们基本只是盯着对方看了三次，玛丽亚现在就要让这个可怕的男人娶她？我简直不敢相信。就在我慢慢适应后半部分的新鲜感、盯着玛丽亚的婚纱看时，电影里的一切都变了。纳粹进城了。极其突然，从字面上的婚礼钟声剪辑到一个巨大的纳粹旗帜在城镇广场上空鸣响。一队士兵阴森森地穿过广场。色彩似乎从电影中流失了。孩子们接下来穿着灰扑扑的棕色衣服出现在石质背景前，而不是前半部分他们俏皮的窗帘装。
The characters, meanwhile, are dealing with their own whiplash. Rolfe surprises Liesl as she's getting into a car.
与此同时，角色们正在应对他们自己的冲击。莉塞尔上车时，罗尔夫突然出现。
Liesl, Liesl!
莉塞尔，莉塞尔！
Rolfe!
罗尔夫！
I'm basically as excited to see Rolfe as Liesl is right here, because maybe this is when we get to the version of the second half I'd been wanting to see, Rolfe and Liesl's courtship.
我看到罗尔夫基本上和莉塞尔在这里一样兴奋，因为也许这就是我们要看到我一直想看的后半部分版本，罗尔夫和莉塞尔的追求。
Rolfe, I'm so glad to see you. It's been such--
罗尔夫，我很高兴见到你。真是……
Good afternoon. You will take this, please, and deliver it to your father as soon as he comes home.
下午好。请拿着这个，在他回家后尽快转交给你的父亲。
Ouch, Rolfe. He's standing in front of a Nazi flag. Liesl is clearly disoriented, but still hopeful as she holds the telegram and coyly asks--
哎哟，罗尔夫。他站在一面纳粹旗帜前。莉塞尔显然感到困惑，但当她拿着电报并羞涩地询问时，依然充满希望——
Don't you want to come over tonight and deliver it yourself?
你今晚不想过来自己转交吗？
I am now occupied with more important matters. And your father better be, too, if he knows what's good for him.
我现在忙于更重要的事情。如果他知道什么对自己好，你父亲最好也是如此。
But, Rolfe--
但是，罗尔夫——
Oh, Liesl, you chose a bad one.
噢，莉塞尔，你选了个坏家伙。
This was the only relationship in the movie that interested me at all as a child. And it's sobering to see the whole realistic arc of it. As for the rest of the second half, it's predictable. You know their first escape isn't gonna work out. It's obvious they'll win the singing contest. Great songs from the first half are just recycled, in a weird way.
这是电影中唯一让我小时候感兴趣的恋爱关系。看到它整个现实的弧线真的很令人清醒。至于后半部分的其他内容，是可以预测的。你知道他们的第一次逃生不会成功。很明显他们会赢得歌唱比赛。前半部分伟大的歌曲只是以一种奇怪的方式被回收利用了。
The one moment that moves me, though, doesn't have anything to do with the characters I was attached to from the first half. It happens, surprisingly, when the dad starts singing a love song to his country on stage.
不过，唯一打动我的一刻，与我小时候依恋的角色无关。令人惊讶的是，这发生在父亲开始在舞台上为他的国家唱一首情歌时。
(SINGING) Edelweiss, Edelweiss, every morning you greet me.
(演唱) 雪绒花，雪绒花，每天早上你迎接我。
He's doing it as an act of gentle defiance that makes the Nazi official's mustache twitch. And as the crowd joins in with him, I feel my throat catch a little. They remind me of people all around the world this summer, in Hong Kong, Beirut, Belarus, here in America, who are longing to hold onto something as their own countries change, rapidly, excruciatingly around them.
他这样做是一种温柔的蔑视行为，让纳粹军官的胡子抽动。当人群加入他一起唱时，我感到喉咙有点哽咽。他们让我想起这个夏天全世界的人们，在香港、贝鲁特、白俄罗斯，在美国这里，当他们的国家在他们周围迅速、痛苦地改变时，他们渴望抓住某些东西作为自己的东西。
(SINGING) Edelweiss, Edelweiss, bless my homeland forever.
(演唱) 雪绒花，雪绒花，永远保佑我的家乡。
The darkest moment of the movie is perhaps at the very end, when the family has almost escaped, but then Rolfe finds them in the abbey. He raises a whistle to turn them in, but the dad stops and reasons with him.
电影中最黑暗的时刻也许是在最后，当时这一家人几乎就要逃脱了，但罗尔夫在修道院发现了他们。他举起哨子准备举报，但父亲停下来并与他讲道理。
You don't really belong to them.
你并不真的属于他们。
Stay where you are.
留在原地。
Come away with us, before it's too late.
在我们为时已晚之前，跟我们走吧。
Rolfe looks scared and boyish. He relinquishes his gun and leans over, relieved. But then the dad takes it one step too far.
罗尔夫看起来很害怕，像个男孩。他放弃了枪，感到如释重负地靠了过来。但父亲把事情推得太远了一步。
You will never be one of them.
你永远不会成为他们中的一员。
Lieutenant! Lieutenant, they're here! They're here, Lieutenant!
中尉！中尉，他们在这里！他们在这里，中尉！
Rolfe chooses to betray them. It's such a sinister and dissonant scene held up against the cotton candy first half. The family still makes it out in time, but in spite of him, not with his help. And that's the actual end of the movie, as far as I know today.
罗尔夫选择了背叛他们。在棉花糖般的前半部分衬托下，这是一个如此阴险和不和谐的场景。这家人虽然还是及时逃了出来，但那是由于他们自己，而不是因为他的帮助。这就是电影的真正结尾，据我今天所知。
So here's my conclusion, having seen it all. You don't need the second half. It's actually better without it. The second half just takes one of my kid self's favorite characters, Rolfe, and makes him a villain, then takes the worst character, the dad, and makes him a hero.
所以看完这一切，我的结论是：你不需要后半部分。没有它其实更好。后半部分只是把我就小时候最喜欢的角色之一——罗尔夫——变成了恶棍，然后把最糟糕的角色——父亲——变成了英雄。
There are barely any new songs. Maria disappears as a person. Liesl just looks uncomfortable the whole time, trying to act like a child for another hour. Everything memorable and iconic about the movie-- My Favorite Things, the kids singing good night, "Doe, a deer"-- that all happens in the first half.
几乎没有任何新歌。玛丽亚作为一个人消失了。莉塞尔整场电影看起来都不舒服，试图再装一个小时的孩子。电影中所有令人难忘和标志性的东西——《我最爱的东西》、孩子们唱晚安、《Do Re Mi》——都发生在前半部分。
But then I was at the beach this weekend with a friend, staring at the clouds and the kids throwing sand. And he said a thing that changed my feeling about the second half. He told me that, lately, he can last about three minutes feeling like everything is normal before he remembers it isn't. It made me understand the urge to include the dark end of this story in the movie about the singing family. Because once everything in the world has changed, you can't really will it to stay outside the frame.
但这个周末我带着一个朋友在海滩，盯着云和扔沙子的孩子们。他说了一句话改变了我对后半部分的看法。他告诉我，最近，他大概只能感觉一切正常三分钟，就会想起事实并非如此。这让我理解了在关于歌唱家庭的电影中加入这个故事黑暗结尾的冲动。因为一旦世界发生了一切改变，你就无法真的强迫它停留在框架之外。
Diane Wu is one of the producers of our show. Her mom, by the way, swears Diane saw the second half of the film as a child, even if Diane doesn't remember it.
黛安·吴是我们节目的制片人之一。顺便说一句，她妈妈坚称黛安小时候看过电影的后半部分，即使黛安自己不记得了。
Act Four-- The Kid Namastes in the Picture.
第四幕——画中的孩子Namaste。
So our show today is about people who watch a film and then have their own very particular take on it. And not long ago, I learned about somebody like that. Here she is in Harry Potter glasses and a onesie with a Gryffindor crest on it, giving her version of the first Harry Potter film.
所以我们今天的节目是关于那些看了一部电影，然后有了自己非常独特见解的人。不久前，我了解到有这样一个人。这就是她，戴着哈利·波特眼镜，穿着带有格兰芬多标志的连体衣，提供她那版的第一部哈利·波特电影。
We meet Harry, aged 10, living in a house. Coming up to stand, take your feet wide, arms out and above your head, house pose. Harry lives at number four Privet Drive with his Uncle Vernon and Aunt Petunia, and his horrid bullying cousin Dudley Dursley. Now, Harry always tries to keep as quiet as a mouse. Coming down to your knees everybody, and tuck yourself up into a tiny little mouse pose.
我们见到哈利，10 岁，住在一所房子里。站起来，双脚分开，双臂伸向头顶上方，房子姿势。哈利住在女贞路四号，和他的弗农姨父、佩妮姨妈以及他那霸凌别人的表弟达力·德思礼住在一起。现在，哈利总是试图保持像老鼠一样安静。大家跪下来，把自己缩进一个小小的老鼠姿势里。
This is Jamie Amor, the host or, I guess, yoga instructor of a series of videos called "Cosmic Kids Yoga." Viewership of these videos skyrocketed during quarantine, from about 100,000 views a day to about a million. And a lot of her most popular videos for kids are her retelling the stories of children's movies-- Moana or Trolls or Star Wars-- and combining the stories with yoga.
这是杰米·阿莫尔，她是一系列名为“宇宙儿童瑜伽”视频的主持人，或者我想，瑜伽教练。这些视频在隔离期间观看量激增，从每天约 10 万次点击量到约一百万次。她最受孩子欢迎的视频大多是她重述儿童电影的故事——《海洋奇缘》或《魔发精灵》或《星球大战》——并将这些故事与瑜伽结合起来。
This spring during quarantine, I watched a six-year-old regularly and very happily do yoga for a half hour with these YouTube videos before starting his day of remote learning first grade. I walked by, and I would just get totally caught up in these videos. And I have to say, a lot of my pleasure and complete fascination with them was seeing the ingenuity that Jamie Amor uses to incorporate the poses into the storytelling.
今年春天隔离期间，我定期看到一个六岁的孩子每天早上在开始远程学习一年级之前，开心地跟着这些 YouTube 视频做半小时瑜伽。我路过时，会完全被这些视频吸引。我不得不说，我对它们大部分的乐趣和完全的着迷在于看到杰米·阿莫尔将动作融入叙事中的独创性。
Like, for example, warrior pose for Elsa, making snow and ice in Frozen. Forward bends as Alice in Wonderland leans over to take a drink from the bottle that says "drink me" on it. In The Wizard of Oz, when the tornado arrives, Dorothy is on her bed-- in bed pose, of course.
例如，在《冰雪奇缘》里，为艾莎做战士姿势，创造雪和冰。当《爱丽丝梦游仙境》里的爱丽丝弯腰从写着“喝我”的瓶子里喝水时，身体前屈。在《绿野仙踪》里，当龙卷风来袭时，桃乐丝在她的床上——当然是床上姿势。
Look out the window. There's that mean lady from the village. She's riding a bicycle in the sky. Lying on your backs, criss cross your fingers.
看看窗外。那个来自村里的恶毒女人。她正在天空骑自行车。平躺在背上，手指交叉。
Bicycle pose, of course. Pada Sanchalanasana.
当然是自行车姿势。Pada Sanchalanasana。
Lift up your legs, and peddle your legs like you're riding a bicycle. She's cackling like a witch.
抬起你的腿，蹬腿，就像你在骑自行车一样。她像女巫一样咯咯笑。
[CACKLING]
[咯咯笑声]
But she's not riding a bicycle anymore. She's on a broomstick with a black cat. She really is a witch. Coming into broomstick pose, lying on your tummies, everyone.
但她不再骑自行车了。她坐在扫帚上，带着一只黑猫。她真的是个女巫。大家趴在肚子上，进入扫帚姿势。
This is Locust pose, Salabhasana.
这是蝗虫姿势，Salabhasana。
And take your arms down by your side, and lift your feet and chest up at the same time, going whoosh!
把双臂放在身侧，同时抬起脚和胸部，发出呼呼的声音！
The videos are actually structured like a real yoga class, always starting with a sitting pose and namaste, and always ending with shavasana, resting pose. And each of the videos plays like a little half-hour yoga appreciation of a movie, though they're all kids films, so Jamie Amor's kid-friendly tone matches them perfectly.
视频实际上构造成真正的瑜伽课，总是以坐姿和 Namaste 开始，总是以 Shavasana（休息姿势）结束。每个视频都像是一场半小时的电影瑜伽赏析，尽管它们都是儿童电影，所以杰米·阿莫尔适合儿童的语调与它们完美契合。
But putting together today's program, we wondered what it would be like if she took on a film that's made for grownups and beloved by grownups, not by kids. So we reached out to her and her husband Martin, who makes these videos with her. And they were into it. And we considered a bunch of different films to turn into yoga-- Silence of the Lambs and Pulp Fiction and Parasite-- before we settled on this film. Jamie Amor prepared this for us.
但在制作今天的节目时，我们想如果她挑战一部为成年人制作且受成年人喜爱、而不是受孩子喜爱的电影会是什么样。所以我们联系了她和她的丈夫马丁，他与她一起制作这些视频。他们很感兴趣。我们考虑了一堆不同的电影来改成瑜伽——《沉默的羔羊》和《低俗小说》还有《寄生虫》——然后我们定下了这部电影。杰米·阿莫尔为我们准备了这个。
Thelma & Louise are best friends. Let's do a hug pose, wrapping our arms around our shoulders, like we're hugging our best friend. They set out for a weekend away in the mountains to take a break. On the way, they stop for a cold, refreshing drink at a bar.
塞尔玛和路易丝是好朋友。让我们做一个拥抱姿势，手臂环绕肩膀，就像拥抱我们最好的朋友。她们出发去山上过周末休息一下。路上，她们在一个酒吧停下来喝杯冰凉清爽的饮料。
Thelma dances with a man called Harlan, coming into our dancer pose. Standing on one leg, we catch our foot with our hand behind us, and lift it as we reach forwards with our other arm.
塞尔玛和一个叫哈兰的男人跳舞，进入我们的舞者姿势。单腿站立，用手抓住身后的脚，抬起脚，同时另一只手臂向前伸展。
Harlan wants to do more than dancing with Thelma, but she doesn't want to. Louise finds them, and is so angry at Harlan that she shoots him in the chest. Coming into our shooter warrior pose, standing one foot forward, one foot back, we bend our front knee and open our arms wide. Pow!
哈兰想做的不止是和塞尔玛跳舞，但她不想。路易丝找到了他们，对哈兰非常愤怒，于是开枪击中了他的胸部。进入我们的射手战士姿势，一脚在前，一脚在后站立，弯曲前膝，双臂张开。砰！
Thelma and Louise whizz off in the car, coming into car pose. Sitting with legs out long, arms forward to hold the steering wheel. Oh, dear. What have they done?
塞尔玛和路易丝在车里疾驰，进入汽车姿势。双腿伸长坐着，手臂向前握住方向盘。噢，天哪。她们做了什么？
On the road, the women meet a handsome, friendly, young man called JD. Thelma rather likes JD and invites him for a sleepover. In the morning, JD wakes up. Coming up to stand, reaching our arms up to the sky, we wave and say, "Hello, sun."
路上，女人们遇到一个英俊、友好、年轻的男人，叫 JD。塞尔玛挺喜欢 JD，并邀请他留宿。早上，JD 醒了。站起来，手臂伸向天空，挥手说：“太阳你好。”
And while Thelma and Louise go to breakfast, JD steals all of Louise's money. Oh, dear. Thelma feels really bad. To fix the situation, Thelma decides to become a robber and steal all the money from a nearby market. Naughty Thelma. Now the police are after them.
当塞尔玛和路易丝去吃早餐时，JD 偷走了路易丝所有的钱。噢，天哪。塞尔玛感觉真的很糟。为了解决这种情况，塞尔玛决定成为一名强盗，从附近的商店偷走所有的钱。淘气的塞尔玛。现在警察在追她们。
Thelma and Louise arrive at the Grand Canyon. Coming to stand in our mountain pose. Standing with our feet hip distance, arms by our side, we become as still and strong as the mountains.
塞尔玛和路易丝抵达大峡谷。进入我们的山式站立。双脚与臀部同宽站立，手臂置于身侧，我们变得像山一样静止和坚固。
They take a breath together.
她们一起呼吸。
[INHALES AND EXHALES]
[吸气和呼气]
Soaking up the incredible view and the peace of this place. All of a sudden, a helicopter thunders into view. Jumping our feet wide and clapping our hands up over our heads. The dust swirls and the sirens scream. Arms wide, we spin, side to side to side.
沉浸在这个地方令人难以置信的景色和宁静中。突然，一架直升机轰鸣着出现。双脚跳开，双手在头顶上方击掌。尘土飞扬，警笛尖叫。双臂张开，我们旋转，从一侧旋转到另一侧。
They're trapped. Thelma looks at her best friend. Listen, let's not get caught. Let's keep going. Louise checks if Thelma is sure. She nods. Louise cups Thelma's face and kisses her.
她们被困住了。塞尔玛看着她最好的朋友。听着，我们别被抓。我们继续走。路易丝检查塞尔玛是否确定。她点头。路易丝捧着塞尔玛的脸并吻了她。
Cupping our faces to feel our cheeks. Louise steps on the gas, stepping one foot forward. As the car screeches forward, Thelma and Louise clasp hands. The car flies off the cliff. Coming into our flying pose.
捧着我们的脸感受脸颊。路易丝踩下油门，向前迈出一只脚。当汽车发出刺耳的声音向前疾驰时，塞尔玛和路易丝紧握双手。汽车飞离悬崖。进入我们的飞行姿势。
Lifting up our back leg, balancing on our standing leg, and taking our arms out wide, we're flying. After all that action, we're ready to relax now. So we lie down and let our bodies feel heavy. We close our eyes and take a big, deep breath.
抬起后腿，保持站立腿平衡，双臂张开，我们在飞翔。经历了这一切行动，我们现在准备放松了。所以我们躺下，让身体感觉沉重。我们闭上眼睛，深吸一大口气。
[INHALES AND EXHALES]
[吸气和呼气]
Jamie Amor, her yoga videos for kids that mix movies and yoga-- but also, there are ones which mix video games and yoga and all kinds of other things-- are at cosmickids.com, or find their free YouTube channel, YouTube.com, Cosmic Kids Yoga.
杰米·阿莫尔，她为孩子制作的混合电影和瑜伽的瑜伽视频——但也有些混合了电子游戏和瑜伽以及各种其他东西——在 cosmickids.com，或者在他们的免费 YouTube 频道找到它们，YouTube.com, Cosmic Kids Yoga。
[MUSIC - AILEEN QUINN, "LET'S GO TO THE MOVIES"]
[音乐 - 艾琳·奎因，“去电影院吧”]
(SINGING) Betty Davis is probably lying, and Greta Garbo is probably crying while Robert Taylor is locked in her dying embrace. Chico, and Groucho, and Chaplin, and Lloyd are all super. Sweet Mickey Mouse, Shirley Temple, and dear Jackie Cooper. Let's go to the movies. Let's go see the stars.
(演唱) 贝蒂·戴维斯可能在撒谎，格 Greta·嘉宝可能在哭泣，而罗伯特·泰勒正被锁在她垂死的拥抱中。奇科、格劳乔、卓别林和劳埃德都太棒了。可爱的米老鼠、秀兰·邓波儿和亲爱的杰基·库珀。去电影院吧。去看星星吧。
Our program was produced today by Lina Misitzis, and Noor Gill. The people who put together today's show includes Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由莉娜·米西齐斯和努尔·吉尔制作。今天节目的制作人员包括苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、塞斯·林德、斯托·尼尔森、娜迪亚·雷曼、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sara Abdirahman. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Jason Smart, David Selassie, Hong Yan, Xiangqian Wu, Karina Longworth, BA Parker, Adrian Shirk, Paul Scheer, Luke, Sophie, and Olivia. And Cecil Ranieri.
我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜迪拉赫曼。我们的执行主编是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢杰森·斯马特、大卫·塞拉西、洪雁、吴向前、卡琳娜·朗沃斯、BA 帕克、阿德里安·舍克、保罗·谢尔、卢克、索菲和奥利维亚。还有塞西尔·拉涅利。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, where you can listen to any of our over 700 shows for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交换）提供给公共广播电台。我们的网站，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过 700 期节目中的任何一期，thisamericanlife.org。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says he has one rule about drinking during the pandemic.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他说他对疫情期间喝酒有一条规则。
Before 5:00 PM, or "prior to 5:00 PM" or "not later than 4:59 PM."
在下午 5:00 之前，或“下午 5:00 之前”或“不晚于下午 4:59”。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
[MUSIC - AILEEN QUINN, "LET'S GO TO THE MOVIES"]
[音乐 - 艾琳·奎因，“去电影院吧”]
(SINGING) Let's go to the movies. Let's go see the stars. Red lights holler, deep Depression. What do we care? Movies are there. Only happy endings.
(演唱) 去电影院吧。去看星星吧。红灯吼叫，深深的萧条。我们在乎什么？电影就在那里。只有快乐的结局。